zahlen manipuliert die intensivbetten
lüge der bundesrechnungshof steckt auf
einige krankenhäuser haben bei den
zahlen der intensivbetten getrickst die
hintergründe zur riesen lüge gleich nie
wieder nackte brüste playboy unter
beschuss julia rommel aus rheinland
pfalz ist das neue playmate des jahres
doch ist diese wahl überhaupt noch
zeitgemäß darüber diskutierte unsere web
redaktion gleich
[Musik]
und damit hallo und herzlich willkommen
ich hier bei bild live ich bin patricia
platin und mein name ist zu den koch es
ist einer der größten skandale dieser
corona krise es ist eine zahl auf die
millionen deutsche sich verlassen haben
die auslastung der intensivbetten jetzt
kommt heraus einige krankenhäuser haben
bei dieser zahl getrickst ja um mehr
zuschüsse zu kassieren
es ist wirklich unglaublich patricia
denn die ganzen maßnahmen die sind ja
auch aus dieser zahl resultiert
abgeleitet worden es ist eine zahl die
unseren alltag in dieser corona krise
bestimmt hat und da haben jetzt viele
fragen
alle hintergründe jetzt mit unserem
politik chef jan schäfer hier bei uns
und philipp fiat auf der chef des
meinungsbild herzlich willkommen
vor euch liegt dieser bericht was geht
daraus hervor
ja ja ich fand einfach mal an das ist
die erste seite des berichts des
bundesrechnungshofs der so an den
haushaltsausschuss des deutschen
bundestages gegangen ist und der birgt
wirklich politischen sprengstoff
erinnern wir uns an den 16 april 2021
bundeskanzlerin merkel spricht im
bundestag wird für die bundes notbremse
für ausgangssperren und sagt die
intensivmediziner senden ein hilferuf
nach dem anderen die zahl der belegten
intensivbetten galt als die harte
währung als der wert der nicht
manipuliert werden kann der total
zuverlässig ist im gegensatz zu
incidents und jetzt wird aus diesem
bericht seite 29 klar
das stimmt einfach nicht dass der
bundesrechnungshof deckt hier auf ich
kann diese entscheidende seite 29 hier
gerne einmal zeigen hier deckt der
bundesrechnungshof auf dass das rk ii
das robert koch institut bereits im
januar
das gesundheitsministerium von jens
spahn informiert hat und alarm
geschlagen hat die haben gesagt wir
wissen von zahlreichen krankenhäusern
dass zu viele patienten gemeldet werden
oder auch zu wenig verfügbare betten und
der grund dafür ist ganz einfach es gab
finanzielle anreize wer weniger als 25
prozent freie intensiv kapazitäten hatte
der hat ausgleichszahlungen bekommen
das heißt
wenn man weniger gemeldet hat also wenn
man gemeldet hat dass man weniger
freiheit oder mehr voll je nachdem wie
man sieht der hat ausgleichszahlung
bekommt das heißt die bundesregierung
hatte ein gesetz geschaffen mit dem
zweiten rettungsschirm im november dass
die krankenhäuser dazu verleitet hat
mehr zu melden die in tänzen die stadt
situation auf den intensivstationen
dramatischer darzustellen und einige
krankenhäuser beziehungsweise viele
krankenhäuser haben das ausgenutzt
philipp du hast schon sehr viel
beantwortet aber meine erste frage liegt
absolut bei den massnahmen ich denke an
unseren unser aller alltag den wir in
dieser corona krise bestreiten
wie passt das jetzt zusammen jan also
wir hätten wir ein ganz anderes leben
jetzt führen können also wir hatten mit
sicherheit ein anderes leben führen
können auch ein anderes leben führen
müssen wenn man sich diese zahlen die
philipp ja auch gerade genannt hat noch
mal vor augen führt die krankenhäuser in
deutschland haben in der korona pandemie
gelitten das ist ein bisschen der
hintergrund jedes zweite war ende des
jahres von verlusten betroffen und so
haben sich die krankenhausmanager
offenbar überlegt das können wir dann
eigentlich tun um an zusätzliches geld
zu kommen und das was findet gerade
sagte dann gab es diese
ausgleichszahlung die dazu geführt haben
dass man dann offenbar massiv an diesen
krankenhausbetten gedreht hat zumindest
gesagt hat wir haben viel weniger als in
wirklichkeit da sind und die große frage
die sich jetzt ergibt ist natürlich wie
hätte ein lockdown ausgesehen oder hätte
es überhaupt einen lock down in dieser
härte und vor allem in dieser länge
geben müssen wäre also unser leben nicht
völlig anders verlaufen hätten auch mehr
menschen ihren job behalten meinetwegen
hätten auch viel mehr kneipen bars
restaurants wieder öffnen können vor
allem auch die schulen viel früher
wieder öffnen können wenn wir nicht
diese gefälschten zahlen gab hätten dem
feld das jetzt auf die füße jetzt müssen
noch konsequenzen folgen die lange ist
dass philipp auch schon dem
gesundheitsminister bekannt und warum
wurde da nicht gehandelt früher also
bild hat bereits anfang dezember darüber
berichtet dass es anreize gibt für
krankenhäuser sich gesund zu stoßen
das bundesgesundheitsministerium wusste
offenbar das geht jetzt aus diesem
bericht hervor
schon seit anfang januar bekannt auch
das lka
das robert koch institut
die wussten auch seit anfang januar
bescheid und offenbar wurde nicht
gehandelt und auch die öffentlichkeit
wurde nicht informiert dabei ehrlich
gesagt lag das auf der hand denn woher
kam denn diese zahlen woher hat
deutschland sich informiert wenn es um
intensivbetten gingen das war der
intensivmediziner verband die wii aber
eben das ist ein verband das ist ein
interessenverband und wie man jetzt
sieht hat er auch die finanziellen
interessen der intensivmediziner und der
krankenhäuser vertreten
also wir haben für alles mögliche
behörden aber hier haben wir uns auf
einen interessenverband verlassen und
dann diese kritik richtet sich überhaupt
nicht an die intensivmediziner die
wirklich im winter unglaubliches
geleistet haben aber der
interessenverband hat das getan was ein
verbände nun einmal tun
und leider hat deutschland sich davon
abhängig gemacht dass ja man muss ja
ganz klar sagen ein halbes jahr lang
haben wir uns auf zahlen verlassen die
es so eigentlich nicht gibt und daraus
wurden corona maßnahmen abgeleitet die
man muss es ganz klar hinterfragen
vielleicht in dieser form nicht hätten
sein müssen
mich macht das fassungslos und ich frage
mich welche konsequenzen hat das jetzt
kommt heute dieser bericht heraus er
liegt uns hier vor
da steht ja auch noch einiges mehr drin
es geht ja auch masken jedes thema wird
einmal angerissen
wie geht es jetzt weiter welche konkrete
forderung jan leidest du daraus also
erst einmal muss der
bundesgesundheitsminister jetzt ganz
ganz viele fragen beantworten in dem
gutachten des rechnungshofes der quasi
die stimme der steuerzahler ist wird ja
auch noch mal deutlich dass das rp schon
im januar gewarnt hat das heißt es gab
im bundesgesundheitsministerium bayern
sparen schon entsprechende warnung diese
fragen sind jetzt zu beantworten ganz
klar christian lindner hat ja auch
gesagt es wird gerade nach der
bundestagswahl sehr sehr viel
aufzuarbeiten geben genau das wird jetzt
noch dieser posten wird jetzt noch
dazukommen und natürlich bleibt die
frage wer wusste möglicherweise von
diesen manipulationen schon im vorfeld
hatten nichts gesagt hat nichts getan
und am ende bleibt die große frage gibt
es auch schadensersatzansprüche die man
jetzt stellen kann weil die
bundesregierung auf falschen grundlagen
ein locker und hängt hat wie geht es
dann mit den krankenhäusern weiter die
stehen offenbar unter einem gewissen
finanziellen druck findet das
angesprochen besonders jetzt in dieser
krise viele intensivstationen haben
wirklich das muss man klar sagen
übermenschliches geleistet dennoch
eben auch immer ein finanzieller aspekt
dahinter wie bewertest du dass wir gehen
ja alle davon aus man geht ins
krankenhaus dort wird einem geholfen
fast schon ein menschlicher
nächstenliebe dahinter steht aber ganz
klar auch einfach eine frage der
finanzierung also die krankenhäuser
ehrlich gesagt die hatten schon immer
finanz finanzielle probleme ich kenne
auch kaum eine branche die keine
finanziellen probleme hat und die keine
finanziellen anreize hat aber der punkt
also dir die schuld liegt bei der
politik denn sie hat einem
interessenverband dem verband
intensivmediziner diese aufgabe von
nationaler wichtigkeit übertragen also
die zahlen die wir über
intensivstationen hatten über den frei
intensivbetten die kam ausschließlich
vom tv und es gab zahlreiche forderungen
von kritischen experten wie
beispielsweise klaus stöhr auch im bild
wir brauchen eine unabhängige kommission
einen unabhängigen rat der wirklich
auswertet was auf intensivstation
passiert dass es nicht geschehen jetzt
muss die bundesregierung wenn ihr mich
fragt handeln und sofort eine
ermittlungskommission einsätzen für ein
untersuchungsausschuss ist vielleicht
reicht vielleicht nicht mehr die zeit in
dieser legislaturperiode aber wir müssen
das aufklären wenn klar wird dass auf
basis falscher zahlen locker uns
verhängt wurden
wenn klar wird dass die bundesregierung
sich auf diese zahlen berufen hat um
beispielsweise wie die kanzlerin für
lockt uns zu werben dann ist das ein
handfester corona skandal und philipp du
sagst ja die politik muss man da
wirklich in die mangel nehmen
schauen wir zu jens spahn also das ist
jetzt noch mal wirklich richtiger
zündstoff in seiner karriere was wird da
jetzt auf und strahlen fliehen jetzt
mitten im heißen wahlkampf ja also er
hatte sicher in den letzten wochen ein
bisschen wieder nach oben gearbeitet
jetzt sparen stand lange lange zeit
unter druck gerade wegen des debakels
auch das test chaos was wir erlebt haben
und man muss sagen die letzten wochen
waren eigentlich ermutigend für ihn er
kam ein bisschen in die vorderhand auch
weil das impfen jetzt ein bisschen tempo
aufgenommen hat aber so eine nachricht
wie heute die haut natürlich noch mal
völlig ins kontor wie gesagt jetzt
sparen muss jetzt ganz ganz viele fragen
beantworten vielleicht kommt noch vor
der bundestagswahl zu einem
untersuchungsausschuss vielleicht auch
erst danach aber er wird noch mal die 10
gerade figur sein und sein name wird
natürlich immer verbunden bleiben mit
vielen dingen die in dieser partie
dramatisch falsch gelaufen sind der
zweite punkt wird sein was wusste die
bundeskanzlerin was wusste sie nicht gab
es falschinformationen wurde sie nicht
richtig mutwillig oder fälschlicherweise
oder unbedarfter weise falsch informiert
auch diese fragen werden zu klären sein
und die dritte frage ist was wussten
denn möglicherweise auch
ministerpräsidenten von ihren eigenen
gesundheitsministern was in den
einzelnen bundesländern in
krankenhäusern vielleicht schief oder
falsch gelaufen ist auch diese frage
wird möglichst rasch zu klären sein wie
viele fragen und einen wirklich
handfesten skandal vielen herzlichen
dank für euren besuch im studio
dankeschön macht wütend patricia oder so
bekommt man sehr schlechte laune
man kann es nicht nachvollziehen so viel
in unserem leben oder eingeschränkt ich
denke an die geschlossenen schulen ich
denke meine kinder irgendwann jeder in
unserem alltag der menschen da draußen
gestützt auf manipulierte sein
lasst uns die laune wieder etwas heben
das sehen wir ja ich schau mal ganz kurz
auf die uhr für sie unter unserer kamera
ist eine uhr und 20 minuten noch
und dann wird sie wieder einen
kollektiven moment gegen der blick in
den himmel
wenn die menschen dann gemeinsam ihre
brille aufsetzen werden mit den dunklen
folien und der blick dann auch wirklich
ganz fest in den himmel geht ja live
jetzt hier die sonne warm ist es so
spannend weil es reicht eine partielle
sonnenfinsternis geben wird und das
passiert sehr selten die letzte ist
sechs jahre her
eine stunde lang wird sich der mond vor
die sonne schieben die sonne also quasi
anknabbern das sieht man im norden ein
bisschen besser als im süden und das
ganze das sehen sie hier live das
verfolgen wir werden schauen was der
motor oben im himmel so mit der sonne
macht also bleiben sie bei uns sie
müssen gar nicht rausgehen sie sehen es
hier
[Musik]
ja so ein bisschen müde sieht prinz
harry aus aber ich bin ja auch sehr
sympathisch es ist das erste video das
er jetzt tatsächlich mit uns allen
teilte nach der geburt seiner tochter
lily bett und er wirkt da so vehement
für sein geliebt für seine geliebte
nentwig des games die in düsseldorf
stattfinden sollen wenn man sieht in die
schlaflosigkeit an lilly betty ist zehn
tage alt und die hat das arme kind schon
mehr skandale produziert als winde sagen
sie heißt ja nach der queen jetzt aber
soll die queen darüber gar nicht am used
sein was wiederum harry so wütend macht
dass er wahrscheinlich router wird als
sein haupthaar sie ja eine überraschung
da was ist da schon wieder los das kann
man sich wirklich täglich nur denken und
wir haben gott sei dank einen oralen
experten unseren kollegen alexander von
schönburg nämlich und der weiß genaueres
alexander was es da wieder los warum
gibt es schon wieder zoff also im
mittelpunkt des streits steht diesmal
die frage ob es die richtige
entscheidung von herrenberg in tibet
lily daher zu nennen und hierbei bild
haben ja schon darüber berichtet dass
das teil kritisiert worden ist aber dass
ein intimer kosenamen die in die
öffentlichkeit getragen es wird auch
kritisiert dass das wir ihnen ein
marketing schachzug von den beiden sei
schon schon das nächste kind als eine
art prinzessin lillifee zu vermarkten
der zukunft also da ist schon da ist
gewaltige musik treten in einem banalen
fragen wie wie ernennen zwei eltern ein
junges elternpaar ihr kind wie schade
dass egal was herr im becken anfassen
also fahrzeug der wind ihn stets
irgendwie unschön und jetzt ist die
neueste wendung ist es sich mit der bbc
angelegt haben denn die bbc also der der
palast korrespondent der bbc hat gestern
berichtet die queen sei nicht um
erlaubnis gefragt worden ob sie ihr kind
die liebe nennen dürfen
und wenn du sagst
dem harry schaut in dem video etwas
verschlafen aus liegt das auch daran
dass die auch nachts damit verbringen
genau zu beobachten was uns in der
englischen presse um ein uhr nachts
kalifornischer zeit haben sie sofort
ihre anwälte in stellung gebracht und
wie sie klagt einige um ein uhr nachts
gingen wir in die oder aus kalifornien
damit dem damit ihre anwälte in london
hat wie deine idee fertig zu verklagen
weil sie überhaupt nein das ist eine
falschbehauptung wir haben die queen um
erlaubnis gefragt unser kind zu zu
nehmen und jeder der das gegenteil
behauptet wird von uns sofort verklagt
er würde so müde aussehen weil er sich
ganz regel beim nächtlichen
windelnwechseln beteiligt bringt ja nur
anwälte in stellung
aber wie geht's jetzt weiter glaubst du
dass es mit prinz harry und die queen
sich zumindest wieder vertragen werden
und sich vielleicht einfach nur auf die
bbc einen schießen wann kommt denn da
mal ruhe in den realen hühnerstall ja
patricia das liegt ja nicht so richtig
in unserem interesse dass da ruhe ist
ehrlich sind die herren sorgen schon
dafür dass da dass da keine ruhe ins
entsteht das tragisch so ein bisschen
ist eine sache ist dass harry sie
beklagt dass eigentlich nur trauma ist
dass er ständig von der presse verfolgt
worden ist er sagt er kickte
panikattacken männer das anklicken von
die kameras der paparazzi hört und
gleichzeitig schüttet er genau dass
ständig weiter dieses komplett
vermarktung seines privatlebens auch
seine und seiner sorgen jetzt geht es in
den extrem nation wird jetzt hat ein
kinderbuch geschrieben
er ist ja auch um die kern geht es ist
ein buch in dem harry die hauptrolle
spielt und an touch also ein weiterer
schritt der selbstvermarktung und jetzt
kommt das nächste snk das nächste was
das dass süßes neues baby genannt wird
nach lilie etwas ja auch wie so ein
marketing manöver klingt damit berlin
gewechselt ist
diesen spitznamen
gegeben es klingt ein bisschen wie ein
strategischer strategisch manöver von
ihnen leider alles was die so ein
bisschen an straßen hat so immer so ein
bisschen den beigeschmack von
vermarktung und selbstdarstellung leider
ja alexander ist es wirklich eine
entlässt orie aber machen wir uns nichts
vor es unterhält ja auch alles uns so
alle ganz schön dankeschön alexander von
schönburg an dich an dieser stelle hat
ein neues lied rausgebracht oder leist
ich hasse kinder ab harter tobak
ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
es beängstigt mich ein bisschen und ich
finde es sehr verstörend habe ich schon
gesagt ihr wollen du hast selber auch
kinder bist mutter was geht dir durch
den kopf wenn du sowas siehst wie wird
schlecht wenn ich dieses video sehe und
ich hoffe dass wirklich kein kind jemals
dieses video sieht welch
menschenverachtung und mich stört auch
neben diesen ganzen blut und gemetzel
diese diese ganze nazi optik ja also
lindemann der wirkt wie sowieso nazi dem
man seinen panzer weggenommen hat und
dreht dann jetzt irgendwie durch und und
welchen billigen texte er schreibt
kinder im flugzeug nerven der mensch das
eher überraschend nichts neues dabei
also ich glaube da bin ich jetzt
komplett anderer meinung hast mich nicht
dafür aber also ich weiss nicht kann es
gar nicht zählen wie oft ich schon
gedacht hatte kindern mir geht es jetzt
hier so offen sagt diese diese bösen
kinder die ihre situation im zug da hat
sie oder du hast ein kind was ich im
supermarkt auf dem boden schleift und
rumschreit da denke ich mir oftmals auch
nervlich ohne hat entweder hast ist ein
großes wort oder es aber wenn wir alle
aussterben ohne kinder natürlich und
nicht falsch verstehen also natürlich
möchte ich selber kinder und in dem
moment meint man es ihr auch nicht so
also ich brauche der festen überzeugung
dass till lindemann keine kinder hast
und mal ehrlich wenn er jetzt anfangen
würde
kuschelrock texte zu schreiben dann
würde doch auch keiner mehr denken okay
das ist das ist nicht krank das einfach
so image pflege bei ihm auf sich finde
ich dass man das auch auf einmal sagen
kann also warum darf ich dann keine
kinder mögen ich zum beispiel ich mag
wirklich keine kinder das kann nicht
ganz ehrlich so sagen ich finde sie sind
laut ich find sie nervig ich fahre dort
mit dem zug ich bin das essen neben den
im zug zu sitzen
ich finde das vollkommen legitim also
mein glück zum beispiel hängt nicht von
in so einem straffen abzocker ich glaube
meine kinder noch nicht kennengelernt
das kann gerne ja das sei ja und dann
wieder schöne kleine nein danke aber ich
glaube lindemann ist nicht klar was er
singt da war doch selbst ich glaube
lindemann will den mann ist sehr sehr
klar was er da singt und ich bin mir
auch sicher dass er das mit absicht
extrem überspitzt weil er das liebt er
liebt die provokation endlich legt es
noch einen draufzulegen und richtig
schön jedem in die fresse zu hauen
wer weiß schon ganz genau was er tut für
mich ist es so gesellschaftskritik hin
oder her vielleicht mag er auch keine
kinder und wenn du sagst ich möchte
keine kinder ist das völlig okay durch
muss sogar den ausmacht ehrlich
schünemann der zeigt doch ganz klar der
hat irgendein problem in seiner kindheit
gehabt und jetzt macht er hier
öffentlich therapie habe der soll doch
mal zum therapeuten gehen nach diesem
video zeigt ihnen jede krankenkasse
sofort eine therapie aus dem vornamen
wegstreichen und dann weißt du genau was
der mann ist also krank ich würde ein
gedanken gerne nochmal auffassen und
zwar gesellschaftskritik hin oder her
dass es mir total wichtig kann man
künstler haben immer eine freiheit die
dürfen sie ja viel für mich hat er aber
eine grenze überschritten in dem moment
in dem er auch über das schlager das
schlagen von kindern thematisiert hat
ich möchte mich diesen satz und wir
lassen uns mal diesen satz einmal
angucken sagt hier kommt die frage aller
fragen kann und muss man kinder schlagen
und da schreien wir ja wohl alle nur
nein nein nein entsetzlich niveaulos
opfer bashing also dieser musiker der es
auch so lange im geschäft das eigentlich
wissen muss welche verantwortung er hat
ich glaube einfach dass wir das alle
nicht gut finden dass man kinder
natürlich nicht schlagen kann
okay auch nicht wenn meine kinder dabei
seine kinder würde ich niemals verlangen
ich würde generell keine kinder schlage
ich möchte immer noch nicht meiner nähe
haben wollen wir uns einmal ganz kurz
von diesem schock
die admin einbuße machen und jahres
wieder den schönen dingen des lebens
widmen nämlich der liebe zwischen
gzsz-star valentina pahde und dem sehr
in meinen augen attraktiven fußball
bosse iday villa weg empfinde ich soll
es knistern die beiden haben ja gerade
zusammen bei let's dance mit gemacht
also gegeneinander angetreten aber
natürlich waren sie immer zusammen und
jetzt sollen sie auf mykonos gesichtet
worden sein und war wohl sehr sehr sehr
verschmust aber das thema hat ja nochmal
anderen komplex liebe am arbeitsplatz
ganz ehrlich ich frage einmal ganz offen
in dem pro runde wer hunde wer hat sich
schon mal am arbeitsplatz verlegt und
bei wem gab es am ende probleme am
arbeitsplatz zusammen mit anderen also
liebe am arbeitsplatz für dich kein
problem denn überhaupt welche also ich
meine bei meinem job muss auch nicht so
als gruppen-erster und online dating ist
irgendwie sowas das ist für mich die
falsche form also ich verliebe mich wie
ich im foto ich verliebe mich irgendwie
menschen in der aura in gefühl und nicht
so ein bild wo ich dann denkt nike oder
nicht like also lena du hast eben den
fingern nicht gerade wenn du sagen ich
finde das auch absolut unprofessionell
also wenn ich auf der arbeit bin dann
ist doch mein job da steht doch dann an
erster stelle da hab ich doch keine zeit
oder auch gar keine gedanken dafür an
irgendwelche männer die darum laufen und
wenn jetzt manche dieser fussball leider
vorbei kommt ein sonderfall weil haufen
ich liebe meinen job und der steht für
mich definitiv über jedem mann allem
aber wieso schließt das eine das andere
aus also du sagt wir sind
unprofessionell bei wir gegebenenfalls
bei der arbeit jemanden finden der
meinetwegen unser seelenverwandter ist
und mit dem wir viele viele themen
teilen können halt eben auch die
probleme im job deswegen sind wir um
profis ist wage ich nicht um das problem
ist es klar gesagt wer sich für mich
oder so nicht ich könnte dass beides
nicht unter einen hut bringen das bag
managers könnt aber das leben ist
eigentlich sagen ich müsste mich
scheiden dass man weiter arbeiten und
das kannst du doch mal erzählen
ihr seid ihr jetzt auch nicht mehr an
einem arbeitsplatz
nee das nicht aber damit hat das nichts
zu tun aber du kannst das ja nun mal
nicht verhindern wenn du mal der mensch
vorbeikommt den du toll finden
weihnachtsfeier 2005 sagte auch wirklich
die ganzen ehen die jetzt nicht
geschlossen wurden in der korona krise
weil die ganzen weihnachtsfeier nicht
stattfinden konnten tragisch und die
kanten wenig geworden wäre ja alles
findet ihr ja gut
also ich nur sagen ich finde
lieberlieber am arbeitsplatz als kinder
weil mich kotzt nichts mehr an als er
online dating ich fühle mich wie im
warenkorb so ein job bei ca
das gefällt mir das gefällt mir nicht
das gefällt mir das lösche ich mal
lieber und das packe ich im warenkorb
das finde ich ehrlicherweise auch nicht
gerade die beste art und weise jährlich
in china galt vor ich hab nämlich diese
ganze sache verpasst aber gefährlich
waren ja auch nicht der typ für war ich
denke dann jedes mal so an die diese
nase ist mir jetzt aber ein bisschen zu
tief und im wahren leben wenn er im
vielleicht vor mir steht denke ich super
also es ist so komplett verkehrte welt
ist eben online dating bin ich raus aber
hat das bei dir 'nen die probleme
gegeben als du dein mann kennengelernt
hast also ich sag mal so wenn man sich
immer so über den weg läuft im job und
dann wird es aber ganz genau wissen
nein natürlich war das nicht gut ich
musste mir sogar neuen job suchen
der fall weil er in der hierarchie ein
bisschen höher stand weil wir dachten
wenn wir das ganz offensiv den kollegen
ganz schnell erzählen dass wir zusammen
sind dass das in einer modernen
gesellschaft mit sicherheit kein problem
darstellt aber die redaktion fand das
gar nicht gut und ich hoffe es hat nicht
den mann getroffen ja aber weil ich auch
kein problem damit hatte mir neuen
coolen job
ok wo also aegon hat sich in dem moment
einfach für die liebe entschieden dafür
viele jahre hoffen als würde ich auch
immer würdest du auch im rachen würde
ich wahrscheinlich auch immer man
ehrlich ist schläfen wird ja nicht ich
finde meinen job steht an erster stelle
und der bleibt auch den kann ich
wenigstens kontrollieren wenn ich mich
gut an strenge gute arbeit leiste dann
habe ich meinen job in fünf jahren auch
noch aber mit einer weiß ich das nicht
aber wenn du 85 bist dann setzt du am
rechen falle mit jemandem neben dir im
schaukelstuhl auf der dachterrasse den
job sitzt da nicht mehr
ja aber das ist doch das kannst du doch
nicht planen denn partner kann auch vor
dir sterben dein vater dein partner kann
irgendwas passieren dass es gibt so
viele möglichkeiten
und da ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
mein job mehr lange erhalten bleibt
definitiv höher
aber entschuldigung gemacht werden kann
es auch er aber daher wird ihr einen
großen fehler ich war weit weg bei 2
mit ihr haben dichtgemacht niemanden der
sich aufhängt ja ich habe mir selber
auch fang ich brauche auch keinen mann
der mich auffängt ja das ist natürlich
ein ganz recht aber ich glaube wenn man
sich für die karriere entscheidet wegen
der liebe und auf die liebe verzichtet
kann man das länger bereuen als wenn man
sich gegen den job entscheiden möchte es
auch bestimmt nicht nach der rente
irgendwie mit uns abhängen oder seinem
coolen typ r war es gibt ja auch so
viele promis die sich auf der
aufarbeitung lina brangelina das hat
natürlich nicht so gut geklappt
ben affleck haben dass ich glaube der
hat klappt ja wieder insofern es gibt
positive beispiele ist gabriel warf ihre
räder haben sich auch bei der alles
stimmen während die werden glaube ich
auch sogar noch zusammen ich wünsche auf
jeden fall valentina und alles gute und
schauen wir mal was aus den beiden noch
so wird weil auf jeden fall wissen wir 1
die informationen dazu bekommen die
lieben zuschauern natürlich ungleich
beispiel gleich ihr name ist groß und
sie ist ein roboter so real ist die
fiktion aus terminator und robert heute
ist grace die zukunft gegen einsamkeit
gleich bei bild live
[Musik]
ja hallo willkommen zurück hierbei bild
live und das sind spektakuläre bilder
aus dem himmel jetzt in diesen sekunden
passiert eine partielle sonnenfinsternis
eine stunde lang wird sich der mond vor
die sonne schieben bis zu 21 prozent
werden hier in deutschland verdeckt ja
ab 11.30 ganze los im norden sieht man
das besser als im süden und wir schauen
hier immer wieder live in eine wie ja
der mond die sonne ab und sieht auch
wirklich spektakulär aus muss man sagen
und wenn man draußen ist sie kennt sie
ja dann mache alles ist wirklich immer
so ein großer kollektiver moment wenn
dann alle menschen draußen stehen und
sich diese kleine pappbrille die kämpfe
auch über den dunklen ja ja sonst macht
man sich tatsächlich die hornhaut
kaputte also man darf niemals so in die
sonne gucken aber gilt ja nicht für sie
sie schauen mit uns und wir haben die
tollen live bilder letzte totale
sonnenfinsternis ist die war 1999 ich
werde das nicht vergessen ich habe sie
damals geschaut ich war im urlaub in
frankreich und salz damit pappbrille und
wusste die nächste werde ich vermutlich
um erleben das wird die einzige totale
sonnenfinsternis sein die ich sehen kann
ich es die nächste dann da 2081 ja ja ja
könnte bei mir auch knapp werden da bin
ich dann 91 99 die letzte totale kann
ich mich auch nicht erinnern da war ich
neun also hier sehen wir jetzt noch mal
bilder aus kanada nicht nur wir in
deutschland können in den genuss der
partiellen sonnenfinsternis kommen auf
der ganzen welt kann man sie sehen hier
jetzt bilder aus kanada und man sieht da
die von rassen ring der sonne und wie
sich der mond davor geschoben hat hier
in deutschland ist es ja so dass man es
im norden besser sehen kann als im süden
also da gibt es ein kleines gefälle so
wie es beim wetter jetzt in den letzten
tagen war in münchen wird zum beispiel
nur sechs prozent der sonne schwarz in
frankfurt am main sind elf prozent und
auf sylt da sieht man die ganzen 21
tja lust auf mehr
und zwar wie meist wenn man sie sieht
dann hat man wirklich schauen sie lust
auf strand und meer aktuelles die heiße
niederländerin in saint tropez unterwegs
zusammen mit ihrem mann niklas castilla
und die beiden räkeln sich im wasser
knutschen und vor allem unsere sylvie
dies sorgt für einen echten hingucker
heißer geht's nicht aber wenn man so
aussehen will dann darf man auch nicht
auf der faulen haut liegen dann muss man
immer schön sport machen wie silvia und
wer jetzt noch immer keine lust hat auf
urlaub dem es wirklich nicht mehr zu
helfen
kritik an schröder urteil
gerd schröder der muss seit 22.000 euro
zahlen warum weil er jetzt wieder
glücklich verheiratet ist das hat
nämlich der ex seiner frau er klagt und
die hat sich jetzt auch auf instagram zu
wort gemeldet hier sehen wir noch mal
ihren ex-ehemann der hat den altkanzler
verklagt und gerd schröder muss jetzt
auch überweisen wegen ehebruch jetzt
meldet sich kim hierauf instagram zu
wort sie kritisierte das urteil scharf
das urteil habe nichts mit einer
modernen gesellschaft zu tun und sie
schreibt ich hoffe dass die koreanische
politik die kraft findet ein nicht mehr
zeitgemäßes scheidungsrecht
grundsätzlich zu reformieren
roboter frau bedient im altersheim bei
dieser frau muss man wirklich zweimal
hinschauen auf den ersten blick sieht
sie aus wie eine attraktive kellnerin
auf den zweiten sieht man es ist ein
roboter
es erinnert an fälle wie terminator oder
ein robot maschinen die von menschen
kaum noch zu unterscheiden sind
und genau das scheint immer
realistischer zu werden
der beweis ist grace sie sieht aus wie
eine nette junge frau die in der
nachbarschaft wohnen könnte unter ihrer
haut fließt allerdings strom durch die
drähte grace ist ein roboter entwickelt
in hongkong grace kennt älteren menschen
die einsamkeit nehmen auch menschen in
einer corona bedingten isolation könnten
mit grace interagieren der roboter kann
schließlich nicht an dem virus erkranken
in ihrer brust zeigt grace eine
wärmekamera und kann damit die
temperatur eines menschen messen mit
künstlicher intelligenz kongress
patienten diagnostizieren und auf drei
sprachen mit ihnen sprechen es ist etwas
erschreckend wie sehr diese maschine mit
dem krankenschwester outfit einem echten
menschen ähnelt ihre mimik entsteht
durch 48 haupt gesichtsmuskeln dieser
menschliche roboter sei überfordert des
kranken personal unterstützen
momentan kostet diese maschine noch so
viel wie ein luxusauto doch wenn
zehntausende oder hunderttausende
exemplare produziert werden würde der
preis deutlich sinken und wer weiß ob in
zukunft menschen neben uns durch die
straße gehen die in wirklichkeit roboter
sind also ich muss sagen ich hoffe ja
doch dass es auch noch menschliche
zuwendung gibt und dass nicht solche
roboter unsere pflegekräfte irgendwann
ersetzen vielleicht sollten wir diese
einfach besser bezahlen dann braucht man
nämlich keine roboter sagst du rollstuhl
für schildkröte ja das sind ja tiere die
sowieso nicht unbedingt flott unterwegs
sind aber das hier das ist george bailey
eine soll kater schildkröte und vor elf
jahren kam sie mit einer behinderung auf
die welt mit einer knochenkrankheit
seine hinterbeine konnten sich nicht
voll entwickeln und sind zu schwach und
können den eigenen körper nicht tragen
momentan wiegt 30 kilo aber er kann auch
an die 100 kilo erreichen sein leiden
hat nun ein ende wie wir sehen er hat
einen maßgeschneiderten rollstuhl und
damit geht es für george bailey jetzt
auch endlich ein bisschen flotter voran
und patricia wir wollen nochmal auf die
sonnenfinsternis schauen wir schauen
jetzt ja schon die ganze zeit auf
aktuelle bilder denn heute findet sie
statt die partielle sonnenfinsternis und
das ist wirklich ein ganz seltenes und
wunderschönes spannendes phänomen
hier sehen wir es auch schon im bild
also der mond schiebt sich vor die sonne
vor 20 minuten ging es los hier in
deutschland das sind noch mal bilder aus
kanada da sieht man das wirklich
spektakulär ganz so sehr wird hier in
deutschland die sonne nicht vom mond
verschluckt muss man sagen bis zu 21
prozent sehen wir hier in deutschland
und das vor allem im norden zum beispiel
auf sylt kann man das besonders gut
beobachten und jetzt gerade wenn sie
jetzt in den himmel schauen der wichtige
hinweis bitte ziehen sie sich die dafür
vorher gesehene brille handel so
genannte sowie modelle man sonst kannst
ja schäden auf der hornhaut geben
trotzdem ein wirklich einzigartiges
spektakel zuletzt vor sechs jahren haben
wir sowas gesehen eine partielle
sonnenfinsternis also wenn man jetzt
gerade auf sollte dann hat man doppelt
gewonnen urlaub schöner mehr und man
sieht 21 prozent also das meiste so und
jetzt gehen wir weiter und zwar zu einem
ganz besonderen mann er ist vom polizei
sohn zum drogenboss geworden und wir
haben ihnen vor die linse bekommen den
schnee könig von deutschland
[Musik]
die polizei nimmt drei dekoriere in
polen fest einer von ihnen packt über
blacky und seine geschäfte mit den
kolumbianern aus
der schneekönig kann nach hamburg
fliegen er weiß dass er in visier der
polizei steht rund um die uhr beschattet
und abgeholt wird
wir sind jeder jahres straße und ich
muss sagen ich habe wieder ein bisschen
adrenalin weil das war meine flucht
strecke dann bin ich wenn ich mich nicht
täusche ja genau hier abgewogen
natürlich nicht solar mich wie heute
sondern schon mit schmackes
ich habe catcher im auto gehabt und
konnte ihr telefon abhören den sieg
bereits ab gehört ich habe erst ab
gehört wenn sie sich unbeobachtet fühlen
wollten dann haben sie gesagt dann gehen
wir mal auf das kleine das kleine war
immer ein handy und damals gab es zehn
netz und ihr zehn jetzt habe ich
abgehört
[Musik]
wo ich da oben an der straße war habe
ich über ihre telefone gehört wie die
den zugriff planten bei zugriff habe ich
gas gegeben und diese ampel habe ich
überquert bin ungefähr gleichzeitig aber
220 230 bin ich hier über yahoo galt
und wenn man jetzt will man jetzt über
diese straße fährt diese so ein leichtes
pop oper soll leichter hügel und ich bin
damals direkt über die kreuzung geflogen
das auto abgehoben wenn man sich einer
verhaftung entziehen will dann kann man
nicht überlegen ob man verkehrsregeln
einhält und da kann man auch nicht
überlegen wie gefährlich das ist
da muss man gas geben
[Applaus]
und entweder klappt oder es klappt nicht
und wenn das nicht klappt ja gut an
landet vielleicht im rollstuhl das pech
gehabt da war der schutzengel zu langsam
die flucht gelingt doch blacky ist noch
lange nicht außer gefahr
er muss sich einen plan b überlegen
nach der flucht brauche ich noch zwei
oder drei monate ja drei modelle in
hamburg dann habe ich ein bisschen
witzig gekauft vorläufig vom freund von
mir
das schiff fahren lassen dass holland
amsterdam und von dort in die karibik
geflogen werden sie ihr kind impfen
lassen oder nicht ganz deutschland
schaut heute gespannt auf die
entscheidung der ständigen
impfkommission
er ist ein besonders schwieriges und
auch emotionales thema für ganz viele
eltern bisher ist es ja so dass erst ab
einem alter ab zwölf jahre und auch nur
bei bestimmten vorerkrankungen eine
empfehlung ausgesprochen wird wir
stellen jetzt die große frage würden sie
ihr kind impfen lassen jetzt bei hier
spricht das volk und dazu begrüße ich
ganz herzlich rudolf konnte er ist
rentner aus stein jehle flüchter diplom
pädagogin und mutter aus düsseldorf
herzlich willkommen johannes flöck
schüler aus ebstorf und auch bei uns ist
olga k paetzke sie ist studentin und
auch mutter aus spenge ganz herzlich
willkommen schön dass sie bei uns sind
herr konrad sie würden sie ihre zwei
enkel impfen lassen
natürlich die stiko empfehlungen dazu
und voraussetzung ist natürlich dass im
stück nicht erst ab zwölf jahren zur
verfügung steht und wenn für alle kinder
kinder kommen nicht mit 12 auf die welt
er hat manchmal den eindruck die
entscheide wie schon gar nicht so wird
auch die einer die kinder gibt und jede
impfung jede impfung gewichtig beide
varianten die durch varianten zu
verhindern
wenn du ihn sogar einige mutationen zu
verhindern die dann eventuell viel
gefährlicher für unfähig hin bewerten
könnte frau flüchter sie möchten ihre
kinder definitiv nicht impfen lassen
warum
naja ich hab mich da schon wirklich gut
schlau gemacht und es ist tatsächlich
einfach so dass kinder und jugendliche
überhaupt nicht von schweren verläufen
oder wirklich kaum von schweren
verläufen mit 19 betroffen sind und dann
stellt sich natürlich die frage warum
soll man dann kinder und jugendliche
gegen einen virus impfen lassen von dem
sie eigentlich nicht gefährdet sind und
schon gar nicht bevor nicht alle
erwachsenen geben sind also auch für die
herdenimmunität finde ich persönlich
der momentan nicht besonders viel dass
man kinder enden soll das ist ja immer
das große argument man kann die kinder
auch für die allgemeinheit impfen
erfolge wenn sie das hören können sie
verstehen dass eltern ihre kinder nicht
impfen lassen wollen
nein also die ema die hat ja schon ihr
go eigentlich dafür gegeben und deswegen
würde ich mich impfen lassen und ich
kann das ehrlich gesagt ich
nachvollziehen auch vielleicht kann man
ja mal mit den kindern sprechen ob die
sich den impfen lassen würde und denn an
der stelle sich dann impfen lassen und
mit den kindern zusammen natürlich und
frauke jaeschke sie haben vorbehalte
auch sagen sie uns dass so etwas ja und
zwar ist es ja im moment ja auch so dass
noch nicht einmal alle erwachsenen
geimpft worden sind und für mich ist
jetzt auch noch unklar wie auch der
geimpft werden muss also auch das jetzt
in zukunft an jährlicher geimpft werden
wird und außerdem finde ich dann auch
die basis also dass das jetzt noch so
kurz erforscht worden ist auch noch ja
fragwürdig weil alle eltern haben sorge
gerade bei kleineren kindern die hier
her konnte ja auch sie angesprochen
haben wie zum beispiel ihre enkelkinder
aber sie sagen ja trotzdem es wäre gut
wenn man jetzt auch mal davor ankäme
beim thema impfen können sie verstehen
dass sowas auch oft skeptisch betrachtet
wird und überhaupt was glauben sie wie
sollte man mit den jüngeren kindern
umgehen also mit dem kindern unter 12 10
sie haben vollkommen recht über die
spricht ja niemand haben sie mich gerade
in die klammen sie die frage noch einmal
ansieht wie würden sie umgehen mit
kinder unter zwölf was ist was würden
sie sich dafür stieg und auch vom staat
wünschen welche empfehlungen und was
fühlen sie auch persönlich dabei sollten
diese kinder geimpft werden denn
nachweislich haben sie natürlich kein
das würde hier auch erwähnt besonders
schweren verlauf bei einer möglichen
krone erkrankungen natürlich erstatten
entsprechenden daten erhoben werden und
dann die freigabe die zulassung aber es
ist vollkommen richtig ist muss auch
genügend impfstoff standplätze trikot
stehen wie schon erwähnt worden
wenn ich einmal alle erwachsenen der b3
konnten bisher geimpft werden und man
muss eben vorankommen aber wenn genügend
impfstoff da ist dann sollte auch die
kinder impfung vorangebracht werden weil
das habe ich ja vorhin schon gesagt jede
impfung ist wichtig um varianten zu
verändern um eventuell eine neue
mutation die vielleicht von den hilfen
gar nicht mehr erfasst zu verhindern
im zweifelsfall oder die echte infektion
ist immer viel gefährlicher als einige
eben vom dafür häufig die impfgegner
oder oder oder
menschen die eben er etwa etwas ablehnen
entgegen die impfung eingestellt sind
das sollten die eltern eben wissen
wichtig wir haben eine verantwortung für
unsere kinder wir haben eine
fürsorgepflicht für kinder und
letztendlich haben die kinder ein recht
auf gesundheit auch und java die her
anwesen sind stimmen ihn als für das
recht der gesundheit unserer kinder
definitiv zu 100 prozent zu frau
schlechter ist sind ja auch initiatorin
der initiative laut für familien also
kümmern sich auch um die familien die
jetzt alle in der korona krise im stich
gelassen wurden durch geschlossene kitas
und geschlossene schulen
was sagen sie zu dem argument dass wir
es gerade gehört haben eine impfung ist
eben nichts kann nicht so schädlich
seien oder solche nebenwirkungen haben
wie eine corona erkrankung selbst ist
einem als mutter nicht wohler ums herz
wenn man weiß die kinder sind jetzt
erstmal sicher selbst wenn die
erkrankung nicht so schlimm wäre wenn
unsere kinder wir sind auch keine
impfgegner aber sonst irgendwas meine
kinder sind auch abstieg kämpft und das
ist ja ein ganz wichtiger punkt stiko
hat es wird es ja nicht empfehlen und
daran halten sich halt viele eltern und
die stiko aus gutem grund mich empfohlen
und zwar einerseits weil die kinder
wenig davon betroffen sind dann auch
weil man tatsächlich auch abwägen muss
es gibt ja auch tatsächlich im stehen es
gibt eben es nebenwirkungen und wenn die
höher sind als die eigene erkrankung
dann kann man ja nicht sagen dass es
hier um die gesundheit der kinder geht
dann müsste also die gesundheit der
kinder ist ja dann im zweifelsfall mehr
bedroht sozusagen durch die impf
nebenwirkungen und das muss man
natürlich gegeneinander abwägen und
einmal mit seinem auch um die gesundheit
ja da wirklich aber einmal kurz ein
haken die impfstoffe die auf den markt
kommen werden ja vorher schon auch auf
ihre nebenwirkungen geprüft also es
kommt ja in deutschland jetzt keinen
impfstoff auf dem markt der größere
nebenwirkungen hat als eine eventuelle
erkrankung mit sich bringen würde
ich möchte jetzt einmal mit ihnen eine
schnelle abstimmungsrunde machen
impfpflicht für kinder in deutschland ja
oder nein wer dafür ist bitte einmal die
hand heben
eine impfpflicht haben wir also schon
mal keine befürworter impfen der kinder
auf freiwilliger basis
wer ist dafür also die menschen die die
kinder impfen lassen wollen oder kinder
die selber den wunsch haben hier haben
wir ein klares 2 zu 2
das finde ich ist eine friedliche
situation in der wir auseinander gehen
können ich danke ihnen allen ganz
herzlich die gesundheit der kinder das
kann man zusammenfassen liegt uns allen
am herzen und daher nochmal vielen
herzlichen dank dass sie sich zeit
genommen haben für dieses gespräch
dankeschön und heute wird es noch mal
spannend ist wird gleich eine
pressekonferenz geben wir sehen hier
schon die livebilder jens spahn heute
besonders unter druck wird es gleich mit
rwe chef lothar wieler eine
pressekonferenz geben in wenigen
sekunden geht es los wir sehen den
gesundheitsminister ich schaue gerade
auf die live bilder auch schon da sitzen
wir können direkt in die live bilder
gleich rein gehen es geht um die neue um
die aktuelle corona lage hier im land
und wir sind alle sehr gespannt ob das
thema intensivbetten sie erinnern sich
an den anfang dieser sendung
krankenhäuser haben bewusst die anzahl
der ausgelasteten intensivbetten
manipuliert um weitere zuschüsse
einzufahren
eigentlich muss der gesundheitsminister
jetzt in dieser pressekonferenz dazu
auch stellung beziehen ob er das auch
tun wird das sehen wir hier gleich live
gehen jetzt live rein in die
pressekonferenz er lieber er fällt auf
meine damen und herren sie sehen einen
zufriedenen bundesminister für
gesundheit der trend den wir
in den letzten wochen auch schon hier
haben beschreiben können den wir gesehen
haben
der ist ein guter und er setzt sich vor
ort das mache ich an 3s fest die
infektionszahlen gehen runter deutlich
runter die intensivstationen leeren sich
von coop 19 patienten die behandelt
werden müssen und die impfzahlen steigen
weiter auch mit guter geschwindigkeit
wir hatten gestern den zweithöchsten
wert bei den täglichen impfungen seit
beginn der impfkampagne
damit sind mehr lockerungen möglich wir
können wieder mehr freiheit mehr
normalität wagen und wer hätte vor drei
vier wochen gedacht dass wir ins tänzen
unter 20 so deutlich und umfassend in
einigen bundesländern schon einstellig
sehen würden das ist eine sehr sehr gute
eine sehr ermutigende entwicklung
gleichwohl geht es weiterhin darum
dieses erreichte auch abzusichern und
die zahlen noch weiter runter zu bringen
ich weiß nach dem motto immer noch ein
weiter aber umso tiefer wir kommen
gerade auch mit beginn der sommerzeit
desto länger werden wir auch etwas von
diesem erfolg haben und desto weniger
geben wir mutationen die chance sich zu
verbreiten und wir sehen gerade im
vereinigten königreich die eine noch das
eine noch höhere impfquote hat als wir
wie schnell eine mutation dann trotzdem
wieder auch zu hohen instanzen führen
kann und umso geringer wir insgesamt die
inzidenz bringen und halten desto
schwerer machen wir es auch jede
mutation dabei hilft testen und dabei
hilft impfen und zu bleiben würde ich
kurz was sagt in deutschland haben wir
inzwischen eine einzigartige test
infrastruktur aufgebaut
in jeder ecke vom münsterland bis in die
hauptstadt vom bodensee bis zur ostsee
leicht zugänglich und kostenlos für
jeden ein bürger test dieses angebot
wird jeden tag hunderttausendfach
millionenfach genutzt um für sich selbst
sicherheit zu bekommen aber auch um an
möglichkeiten des alltags wieder
teilnehmen zu können ob es der
einzelhandel ist die gastronomie oder
der sport
um diese struktur schnell aufzubauen
haben die wirtschaftliche anreize
gesetzt und die bürokratischen hürden
sehr niedrig gehalten
das haben einige anbieter offenbar
schamlos ausgenutzt
sie haben tests abgerechnet in teilen
sie mir wichtig viele machen ihre arbeit
ordentlich engagiert bei guter qualität
der da aber einige haben tests
abgerechnet die sie nie gemacht haben
und möglicherweise sogar test kosten
angesetzt die es nicht gegeben hat um
das klar zu sagen das ist betrug
das muss mit aller härte des gesetzes
geahndet werden und deswegen finde ich
es richtig und unterstütze ausdrücklich
dass die länder das die
staatsanwaltschaften auch mit der
entsprechenden härte vorgehen bis hin
dass es ja haftbefehl gegeben hat das
signal muss sein betrug lohnt sich nicht
wer betrügt wird hart bestraft auch in
diesem bereich und wir haben auf die
betrugsfälle reagiert indem wir eine
neue test verordnung vorgelegt haben
gestern in die abstimmung gegeben haben
mit den ländern und den bundesressorts
was übrigens zeigt wenn ich das mal in
einem zwischen satz sagen darf es gibt
keine verordnung des bundesministers für
gesundheit die nicht ressort
abgestimmtes mit allen anderen
bundesressorts keine das ist so bei
verordnungen bei jeder verordnung der
bundesregierung eines ministers gibt es
eine abstimmung aller ministerien
insofern ist das natürlich immer eine
miteinander abgestimmte regelung diese
test verordnung sieht vor dass wir mehr
kontrollen möglich machen honorare der
preisentwicklung anpassen
wir wollen natürlich dass testzentren
wirtschaftlich betrieben werden können
kriminelle bereicherung wollen wir aber
unterbinden
ein zweites standbein auf dem weg in die
normalität ist das impfen
47 prozent der deutschen sind mindestens
einmal geimpft wenn wir nehmen's
bereitschaft von 75 prozent annehmen die
sich auch in den umfragen widerspiegelt
dann sind drei von vier impfwilligen im
bereiten
wachsenden stand heute mindestens einmal
geimpft und das ist denke ich auch wenn
wir die entwicklung der letzten woche
nehmen die dynamik die das gewonnen hat
bei allen jetzt zum teil auch noch
warten auf einen frieden aber doch eine
gute entwicklung fast jeder vierte ist
vollständig geimpft hat einen vollen
impfschutz und nun wollen wir heute auch
im rahmen dieser kroner lage ein neues
werkzeug vorstellen dass das impfen noch
attraktiver macht denn mit impfen
schützt man sich und schützt man andere
aber impfen erlaubt eben auch wieder
mehr freiheiten gibt mehr möglichkeiten
und um den impfstatus nachzuweisen gibt
es zum einen den bekannten gelben im
fast den internationalen pass auf der
büro und der wird übrigens auch
weiterhin seine gültigkeit behalten das
ist wichtig auch für diejenigen die
möglicherweise aus welchen gründen auch
immer ist nicht digital wollen
aber wichtig ist eben zusätzlich haben
wir uns auf europäischer ebene und das
war ja der erste wichtige schritt auf
gemeinsame standards für einen digitalen
impfnachweis geeinigt
auf dieser grundlage haben wir mit ibm
probiert bechtle und gastitel den kopf
pass entwickelt und konnten bereits ende
mai also eine woche nach ende der
festlegung der spezifikation durch die
eu mit dem feld erstarrten wir mussten
erstmal die eu spezifikation abwarten
dann haben wir den feldtest gestartet
und nun nachdem diese tests erfolgreich
waren
beginnen wir in dieser woche mit dem
rollout des systems der
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte sowie das
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik haben zugestimmt und
so kann es losgehen wichtig ist schritt
für schritt wenn sich jetzt impfzentren
arztpraxen sowie apotheken an das system
anschließen um europäisch interoperable
impf bescheinigungen ausstellen zu
können
das bedeutet aber auch um auch hier
klares erwartungsmanagement zu machen es
geht jetzt los schritt für schritt
werden impfzentren arztpraxen apotheken
angeschlossen aber nicht alle sind heute
oder morgen schon angeschlossen
also es wird jetzt nach und nach immer
mehr geben die mitmachen die ersten sind
schon dabei aber es werden eben nicht
gleich sofort alle sein können
innerhalb der nächsten wochen sind dann
alle dabei so das so ist die zielmarke
bis ende juni der kof pass in
deutschland für alle die wollen auch zur
verfügung steht entsprechend auf dem
handy man sich das eintragen lassen kann
und vor allem die app jetzt auch in den
app-stores entsprechend zur verfügung
steht nach und nach in den nächsten
tagen und stunden um sie sich
entsprechend runterzuladen
auch die nachträgliche ausstellung des
qr-codes beginnen schrittweise das geht
hier um diejenigen die schon vollständig
geimpft sind
die sich natürlich fragen wie komme ich
jetzt an mein digitales zertifikat viele
bundesländer werden in diesen tagen
beginnen postalisch den qr-code zu
versenden
bei den impfzentren da wo ihm
vollständig personen bereits geimpft
wurden und auch die apotheken werden
daneben schrittweise zusätzlich zu den
impfenden stellen sich anschließend die
ersten haben schon begonnen und können
dann entsprechend das digitale
zertifikat erstellt in den nächsten
wochen werden dann übrigens auch test
und genesenen informationen zu speichern
sein
für genau das alles funktioniert wird
heft jetzt gleich noch mal erklären
ich persönlich nutze das ganze oder wer
das ganze nutzen in der kroner bahn app
wir integrieren es gibt es durch die
zwei möglichkeiten das eine ist die
korona vanek wo neben den testen dann
auch das impfen integriert sein wird
oder es geht eben darum sozusagen das
papier das gerät zu bringen mit dem kot
dem wir auch extra im kopf passt der app
die wir extra entwickelten mit dem kopf
saß und für diejenigen die kontrollieren
müssen in den restaurants zum beispiel
oder im einzelhandel gibt es eine app
die ist dann möglich macht die
entsprechenden zertifikate zu lesen und
zu verifizieren
sie sehen wir hatten angekündigt dass es
dieses werkzeug bis zum ende des zweiten
quartals geben können soll
wir halten ihr wort vor den sommerferien
gibt es eine europäische lösung
impfungen digital nachzuweisen einfach
auf dem handy euro
bei weit gültig der kaufpreis wird dann
in rostock castrop rauxel und
tirschenreuth gleichermaßen verfügbar
sein und akzeptiert werden und das ziel
ist voraussetzung ist natürlich dass die
europäischen mitgliedstaaten jetzt
endlich schnell mit 10 ziel ist aber
dass dann auch in helsinki amsterdam
oder auf mallorca
genau dieses digitale im zertifikat auch
gelesen werden kann und damit setzen wir
als europäische union einen standard den
es länderübergreifend auf der welt
bisher nicht gibt wenn uns das jetzt
gelingt und das ist glaube ich im
größten land in der europäischen union
heute ein wichtiger schritt
dann setzen wir als europäische union
auch standards für den internationalen
reiseverkehr und ums im bankgeschäft
vielen dank an minister habe nur meine
damen und herren die zahlen entwickeln
sich im moment weiter sehr gut die
bundes heute liegen tage sind sident
sinkt kontinuierlich sie liegt heute bei
19 fällen pro 100.000 einwohnern und von
dem 412 landkreisen in unserem land
liegt im moment kein einziger mehr über
100 und nur zu russland kreise haben
eine instanz die über 50 liegt es gibt
96 landkreise die liegen sogar mit einer
inzidenz unter 10
glücklicherweise geht es auch mit den
impfungen sehr gut voran
heute sind rund 47 prozent der menschen
in deutschland mindestens einmal geimpft
und rund 20 bands vollständig geimpft
es werden auch deutlich weniger
patienten wegen co wird 19 und unseren
krankenhäusern behandelt auch auf den
intensivstationen und glücklicherweise
gehen auch die todesfälle in verbindung
mit coop 19 kontinuierlich zurück all
das sind erfreuliche entwicklungen
trotzdem ist die pandemie leider noch
nicht vorbei
die situation die wir jetzt erreicht
haben haben wir erreicht weil wir die
maßnahmen haben und weil wir impfungen
haben
das muss uns auch immer bewusst sein was
man auch sehen muss ist dass die
fallzahlen natürlich immer noch
vergleichsweise hoch sind viel höher als
im vergangenen jahr um diese zeit
tatsächlich die exakt heute zehnmal so
hoch wie am 10 juni letzten jahres
sie können auch regional und nach
altersgruppen natürlich noch immer stark
variieren und die intensivstation sind
natürlich immer noch
sehr belastet und es sterben auch immer
noch viele menschen in verbindung mit
provinzieller aktuell sind es immer noch
mehrere hundert menschen pro woche
wir haben uns in der pandemie an diese
hohen krankheits und todeszahlen gewöhnt
es ist generell schwierig sich solche
zahlen vorzustellen aber wir dürfen
nicht vergessen hinter jeder dieser zahl
stehen menschen menschen mit ihren
familien freunden und nachbarn
wir haben gemeinsam viel erreicht in den
letzten monaten aber wie gesagt die
pandemie ist leider noch nicht vorbei
und das wird besonders sichtbar wenn wir
uns die situation in alten und
pflegeheimen anschauen in der zweiten
welle
da waren alten und pflegeheime massiv
betroffen in den letzten januarwoche 20
21 wurden mehr als 450 ausbrüche
registriert danach gingen die ausbrüche
sehr zurück das lag zum einen daten dass
durch die maßnahmen die inzidenz in der
bevölkerung generell zurückging und das
lag natürlich auch daran dass immer mehr
menschen in altenpflegeheimen geimpft
wurden
obwohl es dann zur dritten welle
gekommen ist obwohl die instanzen in der
gesamtbevölkerung wieder stark
angestiegen sind blieb die zahl der
ausbrüche in den altersheimen die durch
sind deutlich weniger bewohner erkrankt
oder gestorben
das spricht für eine hohe wirksamkeit
der impfung aber die ausbrüche in alten-
und pflegeheim sind trotzdem noch nicht
vollständig verschwunden wenn wir hier
sprechen sind aktuell 40 ausbrüche immer
noch aktiv auch mit hospitalisierung und
todesfällen dafür gibt es drei gründe
sind nicht immer alle bewohner gehen zum
beispiel ungeimpfte neuzugänge auch das
personal ist nicht immer gfk sind die
anteile sehr unterschiedlich in den
einzelnen halben und dazu kommen dass
die impfstoffe zwar sehr wirksam beim
verhindern von symptomatischen
erkrankungen und todesfällen sind aber
geimpfte können sie eben trotzdem noch
infizieren
das virus ergreift also jede noch so
kleine chance
wir sollten nicht geben das zeigt wie
wichtig ist zusätzlich zu den impfungen
ist weiter schutzmaßnahmen einzuhalten
und das zeigt auch dass selbst bei einem
hohen impfquoten in diesen sehr wohl
nahbereich nur vorsichtig gelockert
werden darf die gefahr ist eben noch
nicht vorüber das saas kauf 2 virus das
wird auch nicht mehr verschwinden
entscheidend ist dass wir das virus
unter kontrolle halten und auch unter
kontrolle bringen langfristig deshalb
müssen wir die fallzahlen weiter senken
sind immer noch zu hoch und wir müssen
vor allem die fallzahl auch niedrig
halten kontinuierlich
das ist mit impfungen alleine moment
noch nicht zu erreichen denn viele
menschen sind ja noch nicht geimpft und
den entsprechend noch nicht geschützt
deshalb bleiben die basismaßnahmen
vorerst weiter so wichtig die asl regeln
die reduktion von kontakten das testen
die nutzen der korona warnen die
isolierung quarantäne um
infektionsketten zu verhindern und
einige mehr sie kennen alle die
werkzeuge und jedes dieser werke hat
einen wert und deshalb bleibt es weiter
so wichtig auch kontrolliert und
umsichtig zu öffnen
die zeitlichen abschnitten das gilt auch
dann wenn jetzt in immer mehr
landkreisen eine sehr niedrige sieben
tage ins events vorkommt unter zehn ja
sogar 0 hatten wir ja aber auch dann
müssen wir uns unser umfeld weiterhin
schützen und umsichtig verhalten und
unsere kontakte gering halten
denn diese sieben tage incidents ist
natürlich immer nur eine momentaufnahme
sie kann sich rasch wieder ändern das
virus kann jederzeit wieder mitgebracht
werden oder es kann vor ort infektionen
geben die nicht kleckert wurden und die
zur roten ansteckung führen einige
sieben tage city dance ist ein
großartiger erfolg
sie bedeutet aber eben leider nicht dass
alles überstanden ist und das virus
nicht mehr zurückkommt wir alle wünschen
uns öffnungen und normalität
aber das geht nur wenn wir das virus
weiter gemeinsam unter kontrolle bringen
und auch unter kontrolle halten
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir haben
die ausstellung des zertifikats in den
vergangenen tagen in impfzentren und in
einigen arztpraxen in deutschland
erfolgreich verprobt wir werden heute
nicht nur den produktiven feldtest
beenden sondern wir werden beginnen den
produktiven wirkbetrieb schritt für
schritt in deutschland zu aktivieren
auf der anderen seite werden wir aber
auch den bürgerinnen und bürgern
möglichkeit offerieren dass sie ihre
digitalen zertifikate in einer mobilen
anwendung nämlich dem kopf pass digital
verwalten können
hierzu ist zu sagen dass die anwendung
einfach durch jung und alt zu bedienen
ist und im wesentlichen sich durch drei
relevante merkmale auszeichnet zum einen
natürlich das abfotografieren des qr
codes vom im zertifikat und der
anschließenden speicherung
ausschließlich auf dem mobilen gerät des
bürgers und der bürgerinnen zum zweiten
ein integrität check wir akzeptieren nur
im zertifikate die eu konform sind und
die von autorisierten stellen in
deutschland ausgestellt sind von den
ärzten von den impfzentren und in
zukunft auch von den apotheken und
drittens werden wir signalisieren ob ein
vollständiger impfstatus vorliegt unter
beachtung der fachlichen regeln
so ist zum beispiel der vollständige im
schuss zur zeit nur dann gegeben wenn 14
tage nach der zweiten impfung vergangen
sind
die mobile anwendung kopf pass ist
mittlerweile in den app stores
verfügbar in allen drei üblichen app
stores verfügbar
sie kann heruntergeladen werden und
natürlich auch und das hoffe ich sehr
stark auch mit positivem feedback für
das projektteam versehen werden
gestatten sie mir an dieser stelle herr
minister schwachen als angedeutet wir
hatten zehn tage seit vorliegen der eu
spezifikation und in diesen zehn tagen
hat nicht nur das projektteam der wm
sondern auch unsere partner insbesondere
jubelt die kollegen von buffed digital
von bechtle aber auch die mitarbeiter
des bundesministeriums und des lka sehr
intensiv gearbeitet wie auch die
impfzentrum mitarbeiter und die kollegen
in den kassenärztlichen vereinigungen
und in den arztpraxen
wir haben es geschafft in dieser kurzen
zeit das system an die rampe zu fahren
und nun für die bürgerinnen und bürger
nutzbar zu haben
wir werden das wurde angedeutet nun
schritt für schritt die impfzentren
befähigen des imf zertifikat
auszustellen das ist bereits gestartet
wir haben jetzt schon in der fläche
vierstellige produktive im zertifikate
in deutschland verfügbar
und wir werden natürlich ebenso schritt
für schritt jetzt die einzelnen
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen und damit
die arztpraxen in den bundesländern
aktivieren
gleichermaßen werden die bundesländer
befähigt dass die bereits geimpften
zertifikate jetzt ausgestellt werden
können und vor der sommerpause
postalisch den bürgerinnen und bürgern
zur verfügung gestellt werden
die sommerpause ist noch mal ein gutes
stichwort
wir wollen natürlich dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger das zertifikat
für ihre reise nutzen können wir haben
dazu uns sehr bemüht in der ersten
gruppe der mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union dabei zu sein und bei
den ersten eu interoperabilitätstests
das zertifikat zu verpesten
das ist wichtig dass die zertifikate die
hier in deutschland erzeugt werden auch
in den ländern der europäischen union
gelesen werden
und auf der anderen seite konnten wir
nachweisen dass die zertifikate die in
anderen mitgliedstaaten erzeugt werden
auch hier in deutschland geprüft werden
können
wie soll die prüfung erfolgen auch dafür
gibt es eine zweite mobile applikation
das ist der kopf pass der die
zertifikate der bürgerinnen und bürger
einlesen kann zum beispiel am flughafen
oder in anderen lokationen und wo dem
bürger signalisiert wird dass er einen
vollständigen impfschutz zur verfügung
hat und insofern seine reise fortsetzen
kann
beide mobile anwendungen sind verfügbar
der kopf pass und der kauf passt check
und wir freuen uns auf eine intensive
nutzung durch die bürgerinnen und bürger
vielen dank vielen dank hier kommen die
tagung hat und insofern seien reise
fortsetzen kann
beide mobile anwendungen sind verfügbar
der kopf pass und der kauf passt check
und wir freuen uns auf eine intensive
nutzung durch die bürgerinnen und bürger
vielen dank vielen dank herr fritz wir
kommen nicht gemerkt ich habe ich gesagt
jupiter offensichtlich sitzt in köln
aber wir kommen zu ihren fragen und
beginnen drüben auf der rechten seite
schön dank die frage geht an minister
sparen beim digitalen impfpass sollen
beispielsweise die apotheken pro
generierten qr-code glaube 18 euro
abrechnen dürfen die frage ist wie kommt
können sie erklären wie dieser preis
zustande kommt
also zuerst einmal geht es ja hier vor
allem die nachträgliche erstellung
dieses zertifikats bei denjenigen die
schon vollständig geimpft sind aber eben
jetzt die noch nicht kriegen konnten
ansonsten ist ja der regelhafte prozess
klar manch einer mag sich später
entscheiden aber viele werden ja mit
ihrer vollständigen impfung sich im
impfzentrum in der arztpraxis ist auch
ausstellen lassen
und jetzt geht es um die frage wie das
möglichst schnell auch nachholen können
für
die fast jeder ich habs gerade gesagt
jeder vierte ist schon voll geschützt
für die vielen millionen die schon im
vollständigen impfschutz haben und das
digital haben wollen
viele werden angeschrieben werden können
da wird es relativ kostengünstig laufen
durch die länder und dann ein qr code
bekommen den sie einst kennen können
übrigens man kann ja nicht den von
seinem bruder benutzen weil natürlich
der name und das geburtsdatum mit dabei
ist und damit auch der personalausweis
natürlich immer mit gecheckt werden
können soll an der an der stelle
es werden arztpraxen nach tragen können
da geht es dann nach aufwand es wird
jetzt nach und nach das haben wir auch
beauftragt in den taxis softwaresystemen
der arztpraxen sozusagen integriert da
ist der aufwand deutlich geringer da
gibt es dann eine niedrige einstellige
euro vergütung oder es muss wirklich
händisch gemacht werden
da gibt es eine höhere vergütung da sind
wir bei der vergütung der apotheken 18
euro für eine prüfung die ja auch
vorzunehmen ist es geht ja sowohl in der
arztpraxis über in der apotheke um eine
dokumentenprüfung das ist ja nicht
einfach nur mal gescannt sondern es
sollen und apotheker sind darin geübt
dokumente zu prüfen
auch bei den rezepten beispielsweise
gibt es durchaus den versuch von
fälschungen und bei rezepten und es soll
eben eine tatsächliche prüfung
stattfinden mit entsprechendem
kontrollaufwand und der spiegelt sich
eben in dieser vergütung dann wieder
richtig ist es geht hier vor allem um
diejenigen die nachträglich das
eintragen lassen und es geht eben um
diejenigen die jetzt auch nicht
schriftlich werden erreicht werden
können weil nicht alle impfzentren wir
haben leider kein nationales register
hätte gerne eines gehabt aber die
debatte war wie sie war kontrovers und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt eben auf
diesem weg machen nachfrage nur ganz
kurz als auch vor dem hintergrund der
jüngsten kosten kritik durch den
bundesrechnungshof ist das ein preis wo
sie sagen er ist nicht zu beanstanden
es ist es ist wie immer beides wissen
sie hätten wir den preis genommen der am
ende den aufwand nicht angemessen
berücksichtigt würden nicht viele
apotheken mitmachen dann würden würden
manche möglicherweise öffentlich sagen
na super die sagen ich kann in die
apotheke gehen aber ich kann gar nicht
weil meine apotheke macht nicht mit
oder sie müssen eine vergütung machen
die den aufwand widerspiegelt damit
möglichst viele der 19.000 apotheken mit
machen sie denn nicht gezwungen als
apotheke mitzumachen und wir haben finde
ich ein hohes interesse dass jetzt viele
bürgerinnen und bürger zügig tatsächlich
auch zügig tatsächlich auch ihre nach
eintragung sozusagen machen können
deswegen geht es immer um eine vergütung
die den aufwand auch widerspiegelt aber
es wird von beiden seiten das ist immer
so wenn sie vergütung festlegen
möglicherweise kritik geben am es noch
andere themen gerade die frage von
vergütungen bezahlung entsprechend in
der kritik steht
ich kann nur sagen bis jetzt ist es uns
gelungen die dinge immer relativ zügig
die wir aufbauen wollten in der pandemie
in der notsituation dann auch aufzubauen
intensivbetten sind schnell entstanden
es gebe beschlüsse der länder die zahl
verdoppeln zu wollen der intensivbetten
und des corona kabinetts und diesen
ansatz haben wir damals rechnung
getragen
es gab den wunsch dass schnell test
infrastrukturen entstehen am liebsten
gestern als heute weil man öffnen wollte
und es gibt den wunsch dass schnell
digitale im zertifikate flächendeckend
ausgestellt werden können ohne dass es
in arztpraxen und impfzentren zu langen
warteschlangen und ansammlungen kommt
und wenn es schnell gehen soll und
angemessenen aufwand widergespiegelt
werden soll
dann geht es ihm auch um eine
angemessene vergütung
herr kollege ich wollte auch auf den
ersten großen bericht des
bundesrechnungshofs wonach politik
kommen der ihnen ja massive
geldverschwendung vorwurf also es geht
um die masken für apotheker dann um die
frei halte pauschalen für die kliniken
aber ich wollte auf einen punkt für
sprechen kommen nämlich die zusätzliche
schaffung der intensivbetten wo er jedes
klinikum 50.000 euro für ein neues bett
bekommen sollte 700 millionen wurden
abgerufen das heißt knapp 14.000 neue
intensivbetten würden bezahlt
der bundesrechnungshof sagt er kann
dieser intensivbetten nicht finden
sie konnten auch keine statistik
irgendwie zeigen
ist es für sie ein anlass wenn man jetzt
sieht dass es insgesamt heute nur eine
kapazität von 24.000 intensivbetten gibt
aber geld für 14.000 neue bezahlt wurde
das mal zu überprüfen ob da er
möglicherweise auch wie der
bundesrechnungshof vermutet
mitnahmeeffekte geschehens sind und da
betten aufgebaut warum sind die so
offensichtlich gar nicht existieren
es ist nicht nur anders ist wird er
natürlich in diskussion mit den ländern
von uns schon seit monaten adressiert
wir haben glaube auch zu gestern ich war
gestern auch im haushaltsausschuss jetzt
zu verschiedenen themen da auch noch mal
einen bericht über sand jetzt auf bundes
länder bezogen was die zahl der nach den
finanz volumina jedenfalls geschaffenen
intensivbetten angeht und die länder
müssen natürlich auch ein nachweis
erbringen über die geschaffenen betten
idealerweise und auch das ist unser
ansinnen krankenhaus scharf also auf das
einzelne krankenhaus bezogen
aber wissen sie ist jetzt auch eine sehr
grundsätzliche frage des föderalen
miteinanders ich kann mich an die
gesetzgebung noch sehr gut erinnern
das ist ja alles muss immer man sich
noch mal ändern
das alles über ein jahr her die
gesetzgebung zu der intensivbetten
förderung
es gab den beschluss von bund und
ländern die intensiv kapazitäten in
deutschland verdoppeln zu wollen
ich weiß noch wie auch unter anderem
richtigerweise finanzminister scholz
sehr darauf gedrängt hat dass wir klare
zielvorgaben machen das entstehen soll
und dafür klare regeln da sind dann
haben wir ins gesetz den ländern den
auftrag gegeben diese zu verwalten und
zu zuweisen und ich müsste auch im
föderalen miteinander von bund und
ländern davon ausgehen können und dürfen
das wenn länder investitionszuschüsse
ausreichend eingebunden sind an
bestimmte bedingungen bisschen dass wir
eine debatte hatten nokia oder high care
und wir sehr gibt da gesagt haben high
care also höherer standard an
intensivbetten ausstattung dass dann die
vom bund über die länder verwalteten und
zugewiesenen
daneben auch ordnungsgemäß verwaltet und
zugewiesen werden so ist das in der
föderalen struktur übrigens nicht nur in
der pandemie sondern grundsätzlich dass
nicht wenige förderprogramme daneben
auch über die länder in der verwaltung
umgesetzt werden und deswegen kann und
soll das alles natürlich auch nach
gehalten und mit transparenz versehen
werden und das wird es zug um zug der
bundesrechnungshof erkennt den übrigen
ja auch an dass in einer pandemischen
notsituation eben auch zügig hat
gehandelt werden müssen wenn ich es
genau gelesen haben
nach einer nachfrage an haben wir auch
noch in dem bericht des rechnungshofes
auch von einem schreiben des lka an das
gesundheitsministerium vom 11 januar
diesen jahres die rede wo es darum geht
dass sie es sagen dass manche kliniken
möglicherweise künstlich niedrige zahlen
von intensivbetten melden um an
zuschüsse zu kommen
sie berichten davon mehreren e mails und
telefonanrufen dieses el-kaida- bekommen
hat dann zieht es ungefähr
quantifizieren um wie viel ihrer
einschätzung nach die intensiv die freie
intensivbetten zahl künstlich nach unten
gerechnet worden ist also da muss ich
zunächst mal sagen dass ich weder den
bericht des rechnungshofs kenne noch
noch mich jetzt an einen bericht
erinnern kann werden wir prüfen können
wir gerne nachliefern
aber momentan bin ich dazu den
sprachfähig dann will ich zwei fragen
einwerfen online die sich jetzt auch mit
dem rechnungshof berichte beschäftigen
uns damit geld ist eine von herrn wegner
von dpa der rechnungshof den ministerien
bei masken für risikopatienten überhöhte
erstattung an apotheken vor bedauern sie
dass ihr haus bei der balance zwischen
pragmatismus und genauigkeit in der
krise im vergangenen jahr nicht doch
öfters sich mehr zeit gelassen hat und
die zweite frage von den euro
handelsblatt zum impfen ab weiß warum
kann man bei hat man bei der vergütung
der apotheken und ärzte bei fremden
impflinge das auf 18 euro festgesetzt
und steht entsteht bei den ärzten nicht
so die gefahr dass sich die ärzte
bewusst fremde patienten zur ausstellung
des imf nachweise suchen oder ihre
patienten zu befreundeten ärzten
schicken
also zuerst einmal die frage des hätten
wir uns mehr zeit lassen sollen
es ist als hätte ich mir letztes jahr im
märz mehr zeit lassen sollen masken zu
beschaffen
möglicherweise werden dann manche dinge
nicht so wie sie heute sind und
kritisiert werden aber wenn mich
ärztliche direktorin von unikliniken
anrufen und sagen ja sparen wenn ich
nächste woche nicht masken auf dem tisch
habe im krankenhaus dann stelle ich hier
den betrieb ein
dann kann ich nicht drüber nachdenken ob
ich noch zeit habe vier wochen die
rahmenbedingungen zu schicken
das jedenfalls sehe ich als
bundesminister für gesundheit als
oberste aufgabe an in einer solchen
situation zu helfen dass kliniken nicht
ihren betrieb einstellen und zu der
frage der schutzmasken um die es in dem
bundesrechnungshof bericht geht es gab
einen beschluss der ministerpräsidenten
mit der bundesregierung das besonders
verwundbare gruppen vor weihnachten im
dezember schutzmasken erhalten sollen
nicht zuletzt für auch die
weihnachtstage
also gab es tatsächlich ein zeitlicher
dränge dringlichkeit das umzusetzen
und wenn sie sich dann überlegen wie
kriegst du denn das eigentlich hin
in einem land das leider immer noch
keine digitale identität für seine
bürger hat und wo die bundesregierung
wie übrigens auch keine landesregierung
die chance hat die bürgerinnen und
bürger direkt zu adressieren im wahrsten
sinne des wortes weil wir überhaupt
keinen zugriff haben auf irgendwelche
meldeadresse oder sonst was da wie
kriegen wir es hin innerhalb von zwei
drei wochen eine gruppe die schon bei
beschluss der ministerpräsidenten
erwarte deutlich über 20 millionen
menschen liegen würde alleine wegen der
altersstruktur in deutschland möglichst
schnell zu versorgen sind wir
tatsächlich auf dem weg gekommen und ich
bin dankbar dass die apotheken
mitgegangen sind dass wir gesagt haben
das machen wir über die apotheken die
geschaffen diese masten in eigener
verantwortung und sind bereit sie auch
sehr pragmatisch auszugeben für die
phase vor weihnachten und dann in der
phase nach weihnacht
kann man es ja auch mit entsprechenden
nachweisen gemacht und ich kann ihnen
nur sagen ende november anfang dezember
als diese entscheidung anstand waren wir
nicht sicher
es lässt sich halt heute immer alles
anders bewerten ja heute gibt's fb2
masken satt und genug waren damals nicht
sicher ob es überhaupt genug verfügbare
schutzmasken gibt in einer größenordnung
von 400 millionen masken plusminus die
wir brauchen würden wenn man diesen
vollen sozusagen diese vor 15
schutzmasken pro person zur verfügung
stellen will
es haben einige leute angezweifelt ob
der weltmarkt das überhaupt hergibt
weil das meer war als europa da in zwei
drei monaten abgefordert hat
wir waren also in einer situation wo wir
nicht abschließend sicher sein konnten
ob überhaupt in kurzer zeit eine
ausreichende menge zur verfügung steht
und ja im nachhinein im rückblick hätte
ich hätten wir ich sage noch einmal eine
verordnung des bundesministeriums ist
nie eine verordnung die wir alleine
machen die schutzmasken verordnung ist
sogar ausdrücklich nach gesetz im
einvernehmen
ich will das mal rechtlich übersetzen
das heißt es geht nur mit ausdrücklicher
zustimmung des finanzministeriums
erstellt worden weil wir eben gemeinsam
in der damaligen lage zu dieser
einschätzung gekommen sind zu der ich
gerade gekommen bin
klar wenn mehr zeit gewesen wäre und
wenn ich wissen dass ich möglicherweise
schon sechs wochen später hatte schon
sechs wochen früher gehabt hätte hätte
man manches anders gemacht das ist so
das kann nicht konstatieren das kann ich
zu bestehen ohne zweifel
nur wenn die ansage ist vor weihnachten
sollen schutzmasken ankommen dann habe
ich halt nicht sechs wochen zeit sondern
dann müssen wir sehen wie vor
weihnachten schutzmasken ankommen er war
noch die zweite frage nach der
verdrängung also die frage wer jetzt ist
halt wieder die frage was was trauen wir
den ärzten zu und was sozusagen trauen
wir hinzu
gehen wir davon aus dass heilberufler
ärztinnen und ärzte regelhaft sich in
einer solchen pandemie situation so
verhalten dass jeder zu seinem nachbar
praxis seine patienten schickt und der
sich dann von sich von dem seien die
anderen patienten schicken lässt um mehr
abrechnen zu können ist das unser bild
von ärzten und herzen in deutschland und
muss es deswegen eine extra kontrolle
geben oder ist unser bild das das
ärztinnen und ärzte wie auch
apothekerinnen und apotheker in dieser
pandemie ein großer mehrheit sehr
verantwortungsvoll handelt das ist eine
grundsatzfrage die wir uns als
gesellschaft inter pandemie stellen
müssen die wir uns im bundesministerium
für gesundheit stellen müssen
wir gehen aber nach den erfahrungen die
wir einfach haben aus dieser pandemie
davon aus dass dort sehr verantwortlich
gehandelt werden wird
kollegin dann in der reihenfolge der
mitte weiter und dann kommen so
spiekermann und dann ich habe eine frage
zur globalen impfstoff verteilung
vielleicht kann sie sagen wie sieht denn
der deutsche beitrag zur versorgung
ärmere länder insgesamt aus und hat das
auswirkungen auf die in deutschland
verfügbare impfstoff menge zuerst was
zur kovacs angeht es gibt zwei dinge
dass eine finanzierung das andere sind
dosen was kovacs angeht stand der ich
habe jetzt die zahlen von etwa zehn
tagen im kopf die finanzierungszusagen
die andere länder seitdem gegeben haben
kann ich jetzt nicht berücksichtigen war
es so dass eine von fünf impfdosen die
über kovacs weltweit finanziert werden
aus deutschland finanziert werden eine
von fünf wir sind der zweitgrößte
geldgeber und übernehmen damit wie
wenige andere länder eine verantwortung
für die welt aus humanitären gründen
aber auch aus eigenen nationalen
interesse weil wir ein interesse daran
haben dass die welt schnell geimpft ist
etwa mit blick auf mutationen und
anderes mehr
das ist der finanzielle beitrag den wir
leisten
der andere beitrag ist das abgeben von
dosen wo wir uns ja im rahmen der
europäischen union die frau
bundeskanzlerin für uns für die
bundesrepublik für die bundes
regierung ja auch angekündigt hat 30
millionen dosen in die 100 millionen der
eu also frankreich 30 millionen
deutschland 30 millionen zeigt dass
diese beiden staaten im tandem auch
einen großen teil der eu zusage
hier erfüllen werden und wir natürlich
grundsätzlich bereit sind auch in
abhängigkeit von unserer impfkampagne
darüber hinaus weitere dosen zur
verfügung zu stellen
aber wir müssen die richtige balance
finden gerade in dieser phase der
impfkampagne und der pandemie meine
erfahrung ist sie haben eine höhere
akzeptanz dafür auch in der welt zu
helfen wenn es zu hause die dinge beim
impfen nehmen auch gut laufen und
deswegen geht es um die richtige balance
und die richtigen zeitpunkt aber wir
engagieren uns finanziell und wir
engagieren uns und werden uns auch noch
stärker engagieren
in der zahl der dosen die wir direkt zur
verfügung stellen und drittens dafür
weicher als teil der delegation von
präsident marc rauch mit in südafrika
und wir werden unterstützen das
entstehen von produktionsstätten und
kapazitäten auch in anderen teilen der
welt insbesondere afrika nachfrage
können sie das finanzielle engagement
mit sie fand bevor ich jetzt hätte eine
im kopf aber ich bin mir nicht 100
prozent sicher dürfen wir ihnen die
nachliefern die summe die wir zu kovacs
beitragen rolf biedermann ich habe doch
noch eine frage zum bundesrechnungshof
in dem prüfbericht heißt es ist gelbe
unterstützungsleistung aus ihrem haus
nach dem gießkannenprinzip das ist ja
also klingt ja nicht noch
differenzierter geldausgabe und die
andere frage ist warum sie gestern bei
der debatte im bundestag in einer
aktuellen stunde sich nicht in die
debatte eingeschaltet haben sondern
zuschauer rolle eingenommen haben
sie hätten ja möglicherweise zur
aufklärung beitragen können zum ersten
ist das was sich zum bericht des
bundesrechnungshofes der im übrigen
tatbestände aufgreift die alle schon
beschrieben worden sind also jetzt
nichts neues macht nicht per se besser
oder schlechter aber es ist jetzt nichts
neues in diesem bericht drin
in wahrheit
alles themen die wir schon miteinander
diskutiert haben auch hier schon
diskutiert haben in der
bundespressekonferenz
aber sie sind gut vor allem das ist das
ist das was ich aus diesem
bundesrechnungshof und kommt übrigens
nächste woche wahrscheinlich noch einer
zu den masken beschaffungen insgesamt
dennis der haushaltsausschuss hat
übrigens weil das immer wieder ja auch
gesagt wird der bundesrechnungshof
sollte auch die masken beschaffungen
prüfen
das macht der bundesrechnungshof auf
antrag des haushaltsausschusses seit
dezember glaube ich oder november bei
uns auch dazu wird zum bericht geben und
was ich wichtig finde an diesen
berichten ich hab das übrigens
ausdrücklich unterstützt
im haushaltsausschuss als gute idee
warum weil es doch die einzige weg ist
zu lernen
also wir haben also mein haus unser haus
unserer ministerium ist ein
gesetzgebungs ministerium was wir machen
seit jahren jahrzehnten ist gesetze als
wir nicht so häufig machen ist operativ
arbeiten
das ist nicht das bundesministerium für
gesundheit
was wir aber lernen in dieser pandemie
in einer pandemie muss ein
gesundheitsministerium auch stärker
operative einheiten haben und deswegen
eine debatte brauchen ich habe mit
innenminister seehofer gestern
vorgestern noch darüber gesprochen dass
wir reden wollen über die frage wie wbk
bevölkerungs ersten das ausgesprochen
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz ohne
das bbk das lka wie wir strukturen
vernetzt bauen mit den institutionen die
wir haben für die nächste pandemie und
genauso wichtig ist es doch aus einem
rechnungshofbericht zu lernen
erkenntnisse zu ziehen miteinander wie
in einer situation wo die regulären
beschaffungswege und die haben wir ja
erst versucht schaffung sampler zu
beauftragen amtshilfe und die nicht
funktionieren was da eigentlich der
richtige weg ist welche wege nicht so
gut funktioniert haben und welche wege
besser funktioniert haben das kann man
ja nur lernen indem es eben nach blick
noch mal betrachtet wird und dafür finde
ich die bundesrechnungshof berichte sehr
sehr hilfreich
um einfach für eine nächste pandemie
also können wir alles bei der nächsten
pandemie berücksichtigen wenn man nicht
unter zeitdruck schnell handelt muss um
menschenleben zu retten um zu vermeiden
dass kliniken den betrieb einstellen
sondern in ruhe sich über berichte
beugen kann und zu lernen für die
zukunft kann ich das nur gut finden wenn
man noch die zweite frage wie war also
in einigen gefällt
ich habe mich gestern in die sachdebatte
eingemischt und zwar gleich zweimal
mehrere stunden einmal im ausschuss für
gesundheit und einmal im ausschuss im
haushaltsausschuss
mein eindruck ist dass die debatte in
beiden ausschüssen deutlich inhaltlicher
in der tiefe und in der sachfrage war
als das möglicherweise in der
öffentlichen debatte bisher stellenweise
gelungen ist wir haben sehr sehr gut
aufklären informieren können
über den standard cp ca
die unterschiede über die prüfkriterien
über die zeitlichen abläufe die es
gegeben hat über all diese fragen und
insofern habe ich mich den diskussionen
in den ausschüssen gestellt auch gerne
gestellt woran ich mich nicht beteiligen
möchte in dieser phase der pandemie
weiter
wir sind noch mit einer pandemie wir
haben echt gerade eine gute entwicklung
aber professor wähler hat darauf
hingewiesen dass ist jetzt hier noch
nicht vorbei alles und ich kann dem
auseinandersetzungen die nicht in der
sache getragen sind im moment wenig
abgewinnen ich möchte einfach meine
arbeit machen wir machen jetzt weitere
herr kollege dann jetzt
herr professor wieder ersparen
sie haben gesagt die zahlen gehen runter
allerdings sind sie höher als vor einem
jahr die zeit morgen beginnt die fußball
europameisterschaft in wie fern halten
sie public viewing events für vertretbar
und unter welchen maßnahmen na ja wir
haben diese regeln und vorstellungen die
wir seit mehr als einem jahr in unserer
empfehlung geben die haben sich ja nicht
gehen
und das heißt also wir haben konzepte wo
wir ein kontroll cockpit konzept das
haben wir im februar diesen jahres
erstmals publiziert wenn dann genügend
evidenzen hatten für die vorgaben wir
haben wir sagen ganz klar es gibt
bestimmte obergrenzen für
veranstaltungen abhängig von den
entsprechenden indikatoren für uns ist
eigentlich die grandi ka tor gehen sie
denn die andere indikator ist die
belegung der intensivbetten und abhängig
davon kann man dann solche events
stattfinden lassen oder nicht was aber
eben in der verantwortung der
entsprechenden lokalen behörden liegt
das ist der plan den wir vorgeben
wir wissen dass das virus noch nicht da
ist und darum ist es gerade wichtig dass
man diese basismaßnahmen weiter hält
also das was wir wirklich in den letzten
monaten denke ich auch sehr stark
verinnerlicht haben und wo sich wirklich
sehr sehr viele menschen dran halten in
seinem land das man abstand hält wenn es
nicht anders geht wenn es möglich ist
dass man diese hygiene einhält und vor
allen dingen das tragen von mund
nasenschutz oder von masken oder von von
effect 2 mass insbesondere und
nasenschutz das hat einen hohen effekt
und wir kriegen ja immer mehr evidenz
dafür auch also die publikations lage
bessert sich immer das heißt also es
gibt situationen unter dem man einen
bestimmten anzahl von menschen das
ermöglichen kann
das hängt auch von diesen parametern und
es wird letztlich entschieden von den
behörden vor ort wir müssen immer wieder
darauf hinweisen dass sie
das virus durch mobilität natürlich
getragen wird und wir sind prinzipiell
immer vorsichtig und zurückhaltend wir
möchten nicht dass die zahlen durch
solche events natürlich wieder steigen
das ist ganz klar
also ich kann mich da grundsätzlich
anschließen ich meine nein meine
münsterländische heimat ich habe eine
vorstellung davon wie public viewing im
garten als public jungen haben also
öffentliche plätze vor augen aber ich
weiß ja auch wie es sonst so
wahrscheinlich mein stammtisch zu hause
hand haben würde
in normalen zeiten und insofern ist
entscheidend am ende das was insgesamt
entscheidend ist draußen
abstand
vielleicht idealerweise geimpft oder
getestet alle beteiligten und auch wenn
es vielleicht schwer fällt insbesondere
wenn es freude oder weniger freude gibt
alkohol macht per se nachlässiger was
angeht vielleicht etwas in meisterschaft
und wo wenn ich ganz ehrlich sein sollte
hatte ich nicht mehr auf dem schirm das
ist morgen losgeht vor lauter anderen
dingen die mich diese woche schon
beschäftigt hatten
aber morgen abend klappt es vielleicht
herr minister sparen sie haben eben am
beispiel der anrufenden klinikdirektoren
bei der masken beschaffung anschaulich
dargelegt welche rolle auch so
persönliche direkte eindrücke bei
entscheidungsprozessen haben
das erlaube ich mir jetzt auch mal ich
habe vor wenigen tagen mit dem betreiber
einer privaten teststationen längere
zeit gesprochen und die haben gesagt
dass dort an allen ecken und enden
betrogen wird das hätten wir euch auch
sagen können drei wochen bevor das im
fernsehen aufgedeckt wurde als wir die
tests verordnung wie betreiber die
tester ordnung gelesen haben haben wir
gesagt das ist eine einladung zum betrug
wir können bis heute nicht
nachvollziehen warum auf jegliche form
der intensiven kontrolle und
nachweislich durchgeführter test
verzichtet wurde
wie nehmen sie solche kritik auf was
haben sie da eigentlich bei der
erstellung der test verordnung falsch
gemacht oder unterlassen
also zuerst einmal ist es ja tatsächlich
so dass wir vereinbart hatten
auch zwischen finanz- und
gesundheitsministerium dass wir uns im
juni anschauen sowohl was die marktlage
die preislage angeht aber ebenso auch
insgesamt die entwicklung bei den test
stellen um daraus schlüsse zu ziehen und
die test verordnung zu überarbeiten im
nachhinein hätte man das besser vier
wochen feuer gemacht
oder 6 aber es war eben vor allem dem
wunsch dem willen geschuldet sehr
pragmatisch das zu machen um kurzfristig
auch die test infrastruktur
stehen zu lassen die in der dritten
welle erstens sicherheit gibt und
zweitens dann auch öffnung schritte
möglich macht und so ist es hier also
ich weiß noch wenn wir schon bei
anekdotischen berichten sozusagen sind
als sich fink sonntag durch berlin
radelte stand vor jeder test stelle an
der ich vorbei radelte eine schlange
also ist ja nicht so dass ich mir halt
finde ich in dieser debatte das richtig
gewichten
es hat betrug gegeben oder gibt betrug
und auch missbrauch und schwarze schafe
aber es hat auch viele gegeben die ein
angebot gemacht haben das von millionen
deutschen jeden tag genutzt worden ist
und noch wird und das in sicherheit
gegeben hat und gibt für den alltag und
damit in der struktur ist die auch weil
sie schnell entstehen sollte wie gesagt
in dieser dritten welle entsprechend
dann dargelegt worden ist aber es gibt
ein zwei dinge im nachhinein zum
beispiel wäre ich nie auf die idee
gekommen sag ich ganz ehrlich dass in
dem umfang per allgemeinverfügung
beauftragungen stattfinden also das
ganze bundesländer sagen wir beauftragen
nicht in dem der einzelne so zu sagen es
ist kann ja niemand sich zur textstelle
erklären muss ja beauftragt seien durch
die zuständige behörde und der weitere
anbieter so steht es in der verordnung
soll eine ordnungsgemäße durchführung
garantieren
und das bedeutet doch für mich dass die
zuständige behörde sich anschaut
ob den derjenige den sie beauftragt das
kann den räumlichkeiten her von den
hygiene von den abläufen her wenn man
das natürlich per allgemeinverfügung
macht allgemeinverfügung heißt ja für
ein bundesland zu sagen
der folgende parameter erfüllt kann
loslegen ohne sich irgendwas konkret im
einzelnen anzuschauen
das jedenfalls haben wir so nicht
erwartet
das ist wahr und deswegen wird es das so
nicht mehr geben können und alle die per
allgemeinverfügung zugelassen sind nach
einer übergangsphase dann auch nicht
mehr zugelassen und beauftragt sein muss
jetzt eine einzelbetrachtung dann auch
geben und das andere ist das thema der
abrechnung die abrechnungs begründen
unterlagen sind aufzubewahren und zum
beispiel die der auftrag sozusagen auch
die unterschrift die man ja braucht bei
einer entsprechenden testung
des getesteten die sind aufzubewahren
die unterlagen offenkundig ist noch mehr
kontrolle der abrechnungs begründen
unterlagen notwendig und auch
stichprobenartig und auf plausibilität
und auch das bilden bilden wir ab und
auch da sage ich ja mit dem wissen von
heute würde man manche regelungen anders
gestalten
das eigentliche ziel eine schnell
erreichbare erstmal schnell aber auch
eine gut erreichbare flächendeckende
test infrastruktur aufzubauen ist aber
eben tatsächlich auch erreicht worden
und ich habe gestern im
haushaltsausschuss für die vorbereitung
auf den haushaltsausschuss und noch mal
geschaut
ich habe mich an das hier nicht mit ich
glaube es war am 21
februar da gab es diese berühmte
kabinettssitzung über die sie
anschließend auch nachvollziehbarer
weise alle berichtet haben weil da der
erste märz nach hinten geschoben worden
ist als staat beginnen und für diese
kabinettssitzung gab es zwischen olaf
scholz und mir vereinbart eine vorlage
und in dieser vorlage steht drin dass
wir mit monatlichen kosten rechnen von
500 bis 800 millionen euro weil wir
einfach die zahlen der täglichen testung
die österreich zum beispiel ja auch
österreich hat ja so ein angebot
dänemark auch vom bürger test schon vor
uns gehabt und wir haben einfach
hochgerechnet aus den erfahrungen
österreichs was bedeutet das für
deutschland wenn es endlich in anspruch
genommen wird und wir legen jedenfalls
deutlich unter diesen monatlichen kosten
bisher 660 millionen euro die erwähnt
wurden als letzter ab rechnungssumme
sind eine wahnsinnig große summe geld
wahnsinnig viel geld geteilt durch die
test kosten sind es aber 40 bis 50
millionen tests und 40 bis 50 millionen
tests bei 80 millionen einwohnern
innerhalb von vier bis sechs wochen
abrechnungs zeit ist jetzt für mich auch
kein phänomen wo ich sagen muss dass die
zahlen völlig und nachvollziehbar wären
die dort in abrechnung gebracht worden
sind zumal diese summen nicht nur die
bürger tests enthalten sondern auch die
tests in anderen bereich der rationale
kern dieser kritik von betreiberseite
war ja dass sie sagen wir begreifen ist
bis heute nicht warum sozusagen und
möglichkeit gegeben wurde dinge in
rechnung zu stellen ohne sie nachweisen
zu müssen
das ist ja sie sagen jetzt muss ja
aufbewahrt werden ist sozusagen
nachgelagerte stichprobenartige
kontrolle
aber warum was war der grund dafür zu
sagen ihr könnt einreichen wir erstatten
ohne dass es einen nachweis der
tatsächlich angefallenen kosten und
zahlen im verfahren gibt wie kommt man
auf eine solche unterlassung sage ich
mal wie kann das zustandekommen kann ich
ihnen sagen wir hatten ja zuerst im
fokus und eigentlich auch als haupt
adressaten die ärztin und ärzte die
apotheken und die rettungsorganisation
drk und andere die vielen stellen
betrieben haben
bei einrichtungen wird diesen ist eine
regelung die sagt etwa wenn sachkosten
bis zu sechs euro steht da ja auch
deswegen ist sozusagen das was
gelegentlich gesagt wird es würde immer
18 euro kosten ja nicht per se richtig
sondern nach verordnung jedenfalls nach
nachgewiesenen sachkosten bis zu sechs
euro für den test bei diesen
institutionen ist es nicht ungewöhnlich
auch solche mechanismen zu haben das
sozusagen die abrechnungs begründen
unterlagen aufzubewahren sind sie im
nachhinein geprüft werden können und
damit auch ein hohes maß von
verantwortung in der ordnungsgemäßen
abrechnung einhergeht
die herausforderung ist ja insbesondere
nicht nur aber insbesondere bei den
weiter so genannten weiteren anbietern
privaten anbietern
doch da gibt es solche und solche mit
ist ganz wichtig dass wir nicht alle
über einen kamm scheren
und ich will auch darüber berichten ich
mich ja ministerpräsidenten persönlich
angerufen und gesagt herr spahn wir
hatten vorher nicht so umfassend in der
test verordnung vor dem 8 märz in der
fassung wenn sie da mal reinschauen
die die feier gültig war waren die
weiteren anbieter deutlich eingeschränkt
in der frage wer das überhaupt sagen
kann und dann haben wir viele
rückmeldungen aus den bundesländern
gekriegt bis hin zu ministerpräsidenten
die gesagt haben ja sparen wenn sie das
nicht deutlich weiten dass wir deutlich
andere auch beauftragen können dann
werden wir die tests infrastruktur nicht
zügig ausbauen
ich weiß noch wie richtigerweise olaf
scholz und corona kabinett gesagt hat da
steht doch jetzt viel gastronomie leer
viele räumlichkeiten
viele gastronomen haben eigentlich
personal das gerade leider nicht so viel
zu tun hat weil beschlossen
wer ist denn ich eigentlich gut wenn
auch in vielen dieser gastronomischen
einrichtung test stellen entstehen
könnten lasst uns doch sehen dass wir
möglichst viele test stellen entstehen
lassen weitere anbieter haben und
offenkundig ist der mechanismus der im
gesundheitswesen gut weil verlässlich
und auch besser erprobt funktioniert und
besser nachvollziehbar
in dem bereich nicht der richtige der
beste ansatz gewesen muss man ja im
nachhinein sagen und deswegen werden wir
das jetzt eben auch verändern
er kann aber das interesse daran das ist
mir aber noch mal wichtig gewesen dass
es weitere anbieter gibt und einen
schnellen aufbau einer test
infrastruktur ist sehr nachdrücklich
auch und gerade aus den ländern
vorgebracht wird jetzt doch nicht noch
mal zum intensivbetten komplex herr
minister wann wussten sie denn jetzt
ganz genau dass krankenhäuser bei der
angabe der zahl der freien
intensivbetten manipulieren und war die
entscheidung für den lockdown dann
rückblickend betrachtet überhaupt
richtig läuft lang zu hart was
vielleicht ganz falsch also das ist ja
erstmal ein bisher im raum stehende
vorwurf der manipulation
da gab es glaube ich ja und ob die
veröffentlichung eines papieres die zeit
vergeht zwischen 11 34 wochen auch eine
diskussion rund um das sogenannte die
wie register also das intensiv register
und das was ich abbildet und nach meinem
eindruck haben auch viele der vorwürfe
die vorgebracht worden sind entkräftet
werden können fachlich von denjenigen
auch die das intensiv register betreiben
aber wissen sie jeder gerne intensiv
station besucht hat in dieser zeit oder
gesprochen hat mit intensivmedizinern
hat doch gesehen dass wir keine
abstrakte debatte darüber führen ob
unsere intensivstation belastet sind
oder dass das eine abstrakte debatte ist
ob intensiv pflegekräfte gerade am ende
ihrer kräfte sind das war sehr konkret
schon einige hundert meter von hier
in der charité die übrigens jetzt noch
relativ viele patienten hat weil sie für
berlin das zentral hauptsächlich jetzt
noch macht die intensivstationen waren
voll und sie waren sehr belastet die
dort beschäftigten durch cupid 19 daran
gibt es nun wirklich nichts zu deuteln
was die frage angeht so zu sagen welche
intensivbetten gezählt werden in einem
register das ist im übrigen vor dieser
pandemie gar nicht gab
das ist ja auch etwas wo wir gerade im
gespräch sind im rk ii mit der
intensivmedizinischen verbänden wie wir
so was dauerhaft jetzt installieren und
immer besser machen denn seine aussage
kraft die debatte gibt es bis jetzt ist
aber vor allem der vorwurf der
manipulation im raum der sich jedenfalls
als flächendeckendes phänomen nicht mehr
jedenfalls bekannt
erhärtet hat mich wieder auf den
rechnungshofbericht sie hatten folge
setzt die lehrer haben viel gelernt
jetzt noch mal dass ich lerne zwischen 6
euro und einen euro 62 ist eine ganz
schöne differenz wie sind sie denn
damals auf diesen preis gekommen und was
lernen sie daraus und jetzt auch noch
mal zu den intensivbetten kann man jetzt
davon ausgehen dass diese zahlen jetzt
auch stimmen die da angegeben werden
oder wurden wie vieh vorgeworfen falsche
anreize gesetzt
also zuerst einmal was die apotheken
angeht muss immer sehen das klingt immer
noch wenig ist aber bei 19 prozent nicht
wenig die umsatzsteuer ist inklusive
das ist schon eher richtung 5 euro aber
was immer noch im rückblick und
insbesondere natürlich in der späteren
marktsituation im verlaufe dieses jahres
dann deswegen weil sie auch reduziert im
übrigen ja dann was mit hineinkommt ist
die beschaffungs situation also selbst
zu beschaffen und das war im dezember
die herausforderung ist ja ich muss mich
selbst auch immer wieder erinnern und
gelegentlich in meiner aufzeichnung
schauen weil mit stand heute man sich
die frage stellen warum haben wir
eigentlich im november so entschieden im
november war die
lage ende november anfang dezember als
diese verordnung an stand das ffp zwei
man geht einfach noch eine völlig andere
es gab schon verbesserung im vergleich
zu vor drei monaten vorher aber es gab
auch noch nicht das phänomen das wir
heute haben dass die irgendwie im
discount dafür ich weiß gar nicht was im
moment deutlich unter einem euro
teilweise verbot morgen im radio gehört
auf dem weg hierhin von einem drogerie
anbieter selbsttests 95 cent in der
werbung also vor vor vor acht wochen hat
der drogerie anbieter mir noch
geschworen der pricing niemals 102 euro
weil der einkauf und überhaupt und
sowieso wettbewerb hilft
marktinstrumente zu nutzen hilft
deswegen hab ich übrigens gerade beim
thema testen immer gesagt der markt wird
das relativ schnell richten als da ich
mich noch sehr gut wir haben ja schon
ein paar debatten miteinander hinter uns
rund ums testen alle gesagt haben
da muss man aber doch bis hin zu task
force ist ganz anders mit
so jetzt nochmal zu den masken der
damalige marktsituation in der
weltweiten marktsituation und in dem
volumen um das es ging hier ging es
nicht um 10 millionen machen uns hier
ging es um 15 masken für 20 bis 30
millionen deutsche jeweils in einem
volumen dass so wenige länder auf der
welt bisher innerhalb weniger wochen
abgefragt hatten wollten wir
sicherstellen dass diese masken am ende
auch da sind weil ich mir vorgestellt
hab was macht das eigentlich mit den
deutschen und vor allem mit dem
besonders schutzbedürftigen wenn die
bundesregierung sagt wir ständig fb2
massen zur verfügung sie gehen dann in
die apotheke aber dann gibt es keine
was war das denn eigentlich für eine
debatte geworden
von leuten die gesagt haben für
weihnachten und und die zeit hätten wir
aber eigentlich erwartet dass wenn die
bundesregierung sagt dass es masken gibt
es welche gibt
und da mussten wir abwägen und das ist
eben das ergebnis der abwägung da
gewesen übrigens was die gesamten kosten
angeht wir haben kalkuliert mal mit 2,5
milliarden euro steht ja auch im
haushalt dann kam hinzu etwa 5 millionen
hartz-iv-bezieher die in diesen
zweieinhalb
euro noch gar nicht drin kalkuliert sein
konnten weil das ist hat sich ja später
ergeben dass wir auch dort was übrigens
zeigt dass es nie um verteilung aus
eigenem bestand an hartz 4 empfänger
hingegen angesichts einer anderen
debatte die wir gerade haben aber
unabhängig davon sind also 5 millionen
bezugsberechtigten dazugekommen und
trotzdem liegen wir bei den gesamtkosten
bei gut 2 milliarden nicht bei 2,5 mehr
als 2,11 glaube ich wir legen unter den
veranschlagten gesamtkosten
wir haben die leute gut versorgt wir
haben sogar noch fünf millionen mehr
versorgt als eigentlich geplant war
hätte man im nachhinein früher die
preise reduzieren können im nachhinein
ja damals aber mit dem hohen risiko dass
dann die masten nicht vollumfänglich
verfügbar sind und das risiko wollte ich
nicht eingehen
dann habe ich jetzt jede menge an zu den
wetten entschuldigen zu den betten sind
die also die anzahl der intensivbetten
die da angegeben sind ist dass selbst
die richtige zeit wieder angegeben wird
in dem register
das ist das was die ich meine das
register wird der betrieben maßgeblich
von den intensivmedizinern selbst in die
dem verband der intensivmediziner zu
sagen mit dem robert-koch-institut ich
wollte professor wieder sagen ganz so
der frage aber ich unterstelle
grundsätzlich das intensivmediziner in
dieses register hinein das melden was
tatsächlich an gibt es auch
unterschiedliche kategorien sofort
verfügbar in 24 stunden verfügbar
sozusagen nach etwas längerer frist und
verfügbar wenn man in not wäre und also
ich unterstelle dass das schon auch von
intensivmedizinern ärztinnen und ärzten
korrekt angegeben wird
ja also vielleicht nochmal zu diesem
thema weil es ein sehr komplexes thema
ist wir werden in kürze dazu auch eine
publikation noch mal auflegen wo diese
dinge komplex da diese komplexen dinge
dargestellt werden man muss bei
intensivbetten unterscheiden es gibt ja
auch intensivbetten mit oder ohne
partner es gibt verschiedene beatmungs
arten
das ist nicht so trivial das wirklich
auseinander zu halten und das zweite was
in der in der debatte oft auch glaube
ich nicht oder zumindest nicht genügend
beachtet wird ist die tatsache
dass das reine vorhandensein eines
bettes und auch von entsprechenden
gerätschaften wie zum beispiel
beatmungsgerät oder diese eck wo diese
künstliche lunge wie wir das sagen
das ist der eine teil aber der andere
teil ist dann eben das personal das
diese betten betreibt und insofern sind
das natürlich immer vorgänge die auch
teilweise tagesaktuell sehr stark
schwanken
und wir werden das noch mal da legen um
die problematik darzulegen wir haben ja
auch wir haben ich meine ich bin nach
wie vor extrem stolz dass wir so ein
register überhaupt geschaffen haben ich
glaube 20 april oder waren das war das
war ja schon vor weit über einem jahr
und wenn man so ein neues register
schafft dann dann haben wir auch
mehrfach nachgeschärft das weiß ich auch
noch
aber das werden wir alles nochmal
darlegen und ich habe ich habe keinen
zweifel dass die zahlen natürlich
korrekt sind vor allen dingen möchte ich
dem diesem diesem vorwurf der jetzt
vielleicht im raum steht den den ich
ihre frage zum beispiel genommen habe
dass so was wie eine überlastung dieser
station vielleicht gar nicht aber das
finde ich sehr zynisch muss ich wirklich
sagen denn die die wir hatten doch hier
den intensivpfleger einmal in unserer
pressekonferenz reden sie doch mit den
menschen die diese intensivstation
betrieben haben und doch geht es um
leben und tod das sind menschen die mit
mit einem hohen arbeitsethos in einer
krise extrem hoch belastet wurden
und wir schauen uns diese ganzen daten
an wir werden das noch einmal darlegen
und ich glaube dann sollte man die
debatte noch mal führen
wir erwarten natürlich dass
krankenhausbetreiber und die menschen
die in dem system unterwegs sind und
verantwortung tragen dass die natürlich
auch mit mit korrekten zahlen umgehen
das ist ja klar
insofern muss ich dann wohl leider
diesen bericht des rechnungshofs dass
ich ihn kenne aber minister sparen sagt
wir lernen ständig dazu und wir müssen
vor allen dingen transparent und offen
diese dinge diskutieren wie wir sehr
daran gelegen dass dieses register
weitergeführt wird und je besser es ist
sie genau es ist desto mehr hilft
denn es geht ja immer wieder um
quantifizierung von leistungen
quantifizierung von systemen
das brauchen wir in der ganzen medizin
das ist ein gutes modell und das sollten
wir verbessern und dafür heute kurz habe
eine entsetzt wir sind der zweitgrößte
geldgeber beim scp also dem instrument
der vero und eine milliarde euro davon
gehen in kovacs wir haben noch knapp
zehn minuten ich habe noch jede fall
bringen und fragen online die nicht mal
ein paar kleinwaffen herz soll von focus
fragt wird eine heterogene impfung erst
in costa rica 2
im eu ausland anerkannt gab es darüber
gespräche der eu
herr kreis von golem.de fragt gibt es
einschränkungen weil die push up
einsetzen darf sascha meyer von db a
fragt anhalt waren diese für deutschland
mit anderen eu bürgern werden alle
impfstoffe akzeptiert reicht auch schon
erstimpfung und zb zutritt zu
restaurants und kultureinrichtung zu
bekommen wer viel auf einmal also zuerst
einmal meteorologe impfung das ist
tatsächlich bestandteil von gesprächen
herausforderung ist übrigens auch bei
der definition von genesen dass wir
leider anders als man es sich wünschen
würde noch keine europäische eine
europäische unions einheitliche
definition in manchen bereichen haben
das gilt auch für metrologie impfung das
wichtige an dem hof pass ist er
dokumentiert den vollen impfschutz so
dass da gar keine debatten darüber da
sind ob der die entstanden ist durch
astra astra oder bei und montage oder
astra piontek der volle impfschutz wird
dokumentiert und damit ist das dann da
auch hinterlegt die frage der prüf
können sie vielleicht was zu sagen würde
man jetzt sagen nicht richtig informiert
bin
gilt das für alle dass die alle
herunterladen können
us open source kann durch verschiedene
institutionen genutzt werde ich dich
auch unterlagen und und das frage wie
gehen wir mit erstimpfung also wie gehen
wir mit impfungen um die nicht in der eu
zugelassen sind eu vereinbart ist bis
hier hin dass wir
bis hierhin nur eu zugelassene
impfstoffe anerkennen
wir werden sicherlich auch dahin kommen
die eu führt ja auch gespräche g7 ist
das auch immer ein thema gewesen wie am
ende sieben übrigens auch vereinbart bei
den gesundheitsministern dass wir ein
gegenseitiges anerkennen wollen der
zertifikate der digitalen übrigens mein
us-kollege ohne aus dem nähkästchen zu
plaudern haben mir berichtet also dass
wir hier mit 27 mitgliedstaaten
einheitlich eine solche app haben und
ein solches zertifikat schaffen andere
noch nicht mehr mit allen bundesstaaten
und insofern ist das schon was immer man
sich ja auch mal freuen kann dass das
gelungen ist
aber wir haben für die frage wie wir mit
erstimpfungen umgehen als deutschland
eine sehr klare position
wie sie wissen dass die eben nicht
reichen und gerade mit blick auf
variante delta indisch in
anführungszeichen indische mutation
zeigt sich ja dass der volle impfschutz
wichtig ist und deswegen bleiben wir
auch dabei das volk kämpft geworden sein
muss sondern was die andere impfstoffe
angeht müssen wir miteinander im
verfahren finden dass diese anderen
stoffe vor allem eins zeigen nicht nur
dass sie gegen cupid 19 helfen dass die
vero zulassung von impfstoffen ist vor
allem mit blick auf die erkrankungs
vermeidung was für uns aber ja wichtig
ist zumindest noch in dieser phase der
pandemie auch die infektions vermeidungs
zahlen sozusagen wahrscheinlichkeiten zu
kennen
und deswegen werden wir jetzt sinopharm
ist glaube ich gerade in der eu
zulassungsverfahren sputnik v auch wenn
wir die daten kriegen sehen wir wie gut
die auch sind bei den themen und dann
kann man sie gegebenenfalls gleich
stellen das ist aber noch nicht erfolgt
wie kann man ich wollte noch fragen also
habe jetzt verschiedene baustellen
gesprochen
es gibt auch viel kritik hatte die spd
anfang der woche leicht wird sagen
indirekt direkt ihren rücktritt wie
haben sie das wahrgenommen
beziehungsweise sagen sie dazu und ich
habe auch eine frage von einem kollegen
danach frage es gibt mehrere
ministerpräsidenten die jetzt sagen im
herbst holt man doch volksfeste feiern
eine frage wie schätzen sie das ein
also zum ersten was volksfeste angeht
finde ich das sehr schwer das jetzt
schon für herbst entscheiden zu können
so oder so rum und die herausforderung
für volksfeste investiert dass sie
frühzeitig planen müssten idealerweise
die cannstatter wasen und die wiesen
sind ja schon adressiert 1 haben wir
immer gesagt das was als letztes wieder
gehen können wird party so gerne auch
ich feiere aber party
großveranstaltungen feiern karneval
wiesen schützenfest ist leider genau das
wo dieses virus sich am schnellsten
ausbreitet menschen ausgelassen
miteinander in den armen liegen sonst
macht volksfest dagegen wie auch keinen
spaß wenn alle abstand und das ist das
was als letztes wird es wieder gehen
jetzt werden wir in ruhe impfquote haben
und insgesamt damit alles gut unter
kontrolle
aber ich träume werden ob sie sind nicht
zu heute zu sagen dass das im herbst
schon wieder so erfolg geht was die
frage angeht der debatte von anfang der
woche
das hat für mich zwei ebenen der seine
ist die frage der sachlichen diskussion
und die kann und soll und muss man
führen über die sicherheit von
schutzmasken über prüfkriterien
überprüft grundsätze die wir ja auch
veröffentlichen
werden ich habe auch kein problem damit
dem deutschen bundestag die
prüfprotokolle müssen wir möglicherweise
in der geheimschutzstelle machen weil da
auch unternehmensdaten und zum teil ja
noch rechtsstreitigkeiten anhängen aber
die prüf 9000 prüfprotokolle zur
verfügung zu stellen
wir haben in der sache stellen wir uns
jeder diskussion und auch jeder kritik
das andere ist die frage geht es um die
sache oder geht es um anderes mit blick
auf auf sonntage mit blick auf stimmung
und das ist der teil an dem ich mir
einfach nicht beteiligen möchte und den
ich auch einfach hin grundsätzlich
schwierig finde innerhalb einer
regierung den ich aber eben vor allem in
dieser phase der pandemie nicht weiter
betreibe ich werde dazu nichts mehr
sagen ich möchte einfach meine arbeit
machen ich möchte dieses land gut durch
und raus aus dieser pandemie führen und
der rest wird dann was jetzt sozusagen
die bewertung der arbeit angeht der 26
september entscheiden lassen sie mich
noch zwei fragen online einbringen
bereiche von freixenet plagt ab wann
werden die arztpraxen an das system
angeschlossen die frist für ist update
der praxis verwaltungssystem für die
hersteller geht noch bis zum 12
juli könnte es also noch einen ganzen
monat dauern bis auch ärzte das
zertifikat ausstellen können und der
holstein von der apotheke adhoc fragt
ersparen rechnen sie mit chaos wenn
millionen menschen am montag die
apotheken stürmen die noch gar nicht
angeschlossen oder wie die abläufe
informiert sind warum wurden die nicht
gewartet bis die anschreiben verschickt
sind und wirklich alle apotheken
angeschlossen hat
zur ersten frage wir beginnen auch heute
schon über die kassenärztlichen
vereinigungen das rollout in die
arztpraxen
wir haben ja auch überbrückungs lösungen
dass die arztpraxen mit einfachen
verfahren den digitalen umfeld das
digitales zertifikat ausstellen können
gleichwohl sind natürlich die praxis
verwaltungssysteme aufgefordert in der
genannten frist integriert im system die
ausstellung des zertifikats zu
ermöglichen
das wird anfang juli der fall sein
spätestens wir führen aber auch
gespräche mit einigen das das natürlich
auch schneller
passieren kann nichtsdestotrotz wir
haben ab heute die überbrückungslösung
verfügbar
wir haben intensive gespräche mit allen
17 kv geführt und eine hohe bereitschaft
und motivation wahrgenommen dass jetzt
auch in die fläche auszurollen und das
hat heute begonnen
das kann nicht verknüpfen mit apotheken
oder arztpraxen wissen sie das ist ja
auch für uns nicht leicht den richtigen
zeitpunkt für die öffentlichkeitsarbeit
sozusagen zu finden weil seit es ist
jetzt in den app-stores wenn etwas
heruntergeladen werden kann wo keiner
öffentlich was zugesagt hat was es
eigentlich ist ist ja irgendwie auch
komisch es gibt berichterstattung
darüber dass die ersten apotheken
beginnen werden und deswegen bei uns
einfach wichtig hier heute das
vorzustellen einzuordnen
aber eben auch sehr klar zu sagen da
sind wir wieder beim
erwartungsmanagement ist werden jetzt
nicht bitte nicht alle am montag gleich
in die arztpraxen und apotheken sondern
das geht jetzt eben nach und nach ist ja
jetzt mal der druck ist sozusagen
wahrscheinlich auch unterschiedlich
stark
bei den bürgerinnen und bürgern die
einen brauchen das im zertifikat
vielleicht sehr bald und sehr häufig
andere vielleicht erst in drei vier
wochen wenn es dann in die
urlaubsplanung geht und wer als erster
drei vier wochen braucht kann ja
vielleicht dem gesamtsystem noch zwei
wochen zeit geben vor gleich am montag
sich auf den weg macht wir wollten jetzt
einfach nur vorstellen was jetzt startet
es beginnt halt jetzt die apps sind
verfügbar
die ersten impf zentren arztpraxen und
bald auch apotheken beginnen und
gleichzeitig eben sehr klar sagen ist
können aber noch nicht alle gleich
sofort im laufe des junis werden dann
alle angeschlossen sein
und dann schauen sie mal mit 20 19 20
tausend apotheken mitmachen 70 80.000
arztpraxen und 400m zentren
dann werden wir auch einige millionen
und per post
viele sehr viele werden auch die
qr-codes erhalten können das ist per
post dauert die länder fangen jetzt an
zu verschicken
10 14 tage maximal maximal
positiv überraschen besser aber
jedenfalls werde jetzt eine zeit kurze
zeit dauern aber aber wenn dann einmal
so eine infrastruktur da ist dann werden
auch einige millionen in nach tragung
sogar vergleichsweise schnell gehen
können vielen dank wir sind am ende
unserer zeit wie heute alle die nicht
rangekommen sind insbesondere online bei
denen möchte ich mich entschuldigen
herr minister den herren bis zum
nächsten mal dankeschön
das war also die pressekonferenz mit
jens spahn und rk lka-chef wieder unter
gesundheitsminister musste sich der
frage stellen haben die kliniken bei der
belegung der intensivbetten bei der
veröffentlichung dieser zahlen getrickst
und uns im studio unterstützt uns jetzt
unser politik chef jan schäfer noch
ersparen der hat wirklich viel und lang
erzählt aber wie bewertest du das was er
über den intensivbetten skandal ein
fehlt also jens spahn hatte heute seinen
teflon anzug anders kann man glaube ich
wenn man die ganze stunde jetzt
betrachtet ohne groß dass china
importieren zu wollen sagen teflon
anzüge hat die schuld wenn es dann schon
gibt und sich das alles so bestätigt
weit von sich geschoben hat gesagt olaf
scholz hätte ja darauf gedrungen auch
dass es mehr intensivbetten geben muss
hat gilt den ländern den schwarzen peter
zugeschoben hat gesagt er hätte es dann
also auch mehr kontrollen geben können
unser kollege florian kain der hat ihn
ja auch noch gefragt wann denn
eigentlich sparen selbst gewusst hat
dass es da also gewisse
unregelmäßigkeiten gegeben hat das
ministerium soll ja am 11 januar darauf
hingewiesen worden sein
und da die entspannen gesagt dass ihnen
das also flächendeckend gar nicht so
bekannt ist
interessant ist dass er gleichzeitig in
der pressekonferenz auch wieder gesagt
hat dass die dinge die der rechnungshof
jetzt berichtet hat ja eigentlich im
großen und ganzen alles schon seit
wochen bekannt sind also da gibt es auch
eine diskrepanz dem zusammen was er
gesagt hat ganz klar wir müssen einfach
jetzt abwarten es gibt auch erste
politische forderungen schon die fdp
sagt es muss ein sonderermittler geben
um auch dieses thema aufzugreifen
aufzuarbeiten also gab es wirklich
manipulation im großen stil und die
große frage die sich daran schließt
hätte zum beispiel der lock down in
seiner länge in seiner schärfe
eigentlich verhindert werden können war
der möglicherweise gar nicht so nötig
und hat dann auch so viele existenzen
vernichtet wie wir ihnen gesehen haben
wenn es diese manipulationen nicht
gegeben hätte diese frage haben wir ja
auch live in der pressekonferenz
gestellt und auch das persische an den
bundesgesundheitsminister völlig ab also
die frage hätte man die maßnahmen anders
bewertet wenn man die zahlen über die
tatsächlichen zahlen zur belegung der
intensivbetten zu diesem zeitpunkt als
diese entscheidungen getroffen werde so
in diesem rahmen gewusst hätte aber mich
hat auch sehr verwundert dass der
gesundheitsminister gesagt na ja in
diesem bericht steht ja eigentlich auch
in wahrheit gar nicht viel neues
bemerkenswerter satz dafür dass nicht
viel neues drin stand sagte auf der
anderen seite aber auch das ist ihnen
dieser flächen deckende betrug wenn es
ihn dann gegeben hat so gar nicht
bewusst gegeben gewesen ist ganz klar er
sucht den schwarzen peter hin zu den
ländern zu schieben ganz klar das ist im
wahljahr dreieinhalb wochen monate vor
der bundestagswahl sicherlich etwas was
man ihm auch nicht übel nehmen kann aber
ganz klar dass der rechnungshof
adressiert ja jens spahn beziehungsweise
sein ministerium auch in seinem bericht
und er bemängelt dass im
bundesgesundheitsministerium nicht genau
klar ist wie viele intensivbetten
eigentlich zusätzlich geschaffen wurden
beziehungsweise auch wie viele
intensivbetten es den insgesamt
eigentlich gegeben hat also dass es da
gar keinen eigenen kontrollmechanismus
gegeben hat und immer wenn es um das
thema steuergeld geht also wenn eine
regierung mit steuergeldern irgendetwas
finanziert dann ist es auch ihre pflicht
nach zu halten wird denn diese
steuergeld eigentlich sinnvoll
ausgegeben und genau das kritisiert der
rechnungshof genau das ist nicht
passiert und ich glaube da macht es sich
an sparen etwas zu einfach den schwarzen
peter hin zu den ländern zu schieben
hinzu olaf scholz zu schieben oder auch
zu sagen das ist ja alles schon mehr
oder weniger bekannt gewesen ich weiß
gar nicht über was gesprochen hat also
man wird sehen man muss es aufarbeiten
er muss es auf arbeiten zusammen mit den
ländern
da gibt es noch viele fragen und da
werden die nächsten wochen sicherlich
sehr spannend werden
lka chef will ja auch in der runde und
da sind wir alle drei w
der konferenz auch so ein bin ich
aufgeschreckt die reaktion war nämlich
auch bemerkenswert ja oder ja lothar
wieder der lka-chef hat auf die frage
was er denn wisse zu den vorwürfen des
bundesrechnungshofes und es gebe ja auch
ein brief an das
bundesgesundheitsministerium aus seinem
haus vom 11 januar eigentlich nur gesagt
dass ihm der ganze vorgang nicht bekannt
ist dass er erst noch mal nach
recherchieren müsse und dass er auch das
gutachten gar nicht gelesen hat das kann
man jetzt zweierlei bedeuten zum einsatz
lothar wieler wirklich so viele andere
dinge noch zu tun hat und in diese
pressekonferenz rein gestürmt ist und
kein briefing vor bekommen hat man kann
es aber auch als eine gewisse
verteidigungsstrategie sie strategie
sehen nämlich zugunsten von jens spahn
dass er den minister nicht noch
zusätzlich belasten wollte und einfach
gesagt hat ich weiß gar nicht worüber
hier gesprochen wird deswegen kann ich
auch dazu gar nicht sagen sagte ja auch
noch jan ich bin nicht sprachfähig zu
diesem thema haben wir ich wirklich
erstaunlich dass man zu diesem thema
nicht sprach weg ist du warst
sprachfähig zur analyse dieser
pressekonferenz herzlichen dank dir
dafür für deinen besuch hier im studio
denn das war es von uns das war es von
bild live heute um 11 schauen sie weiter
rein auf bild de finden sie natürlich
rund um die uhr alle news und wir sehen
uns wieder morgen früh wenn sie wollen
um 11 uhr sellin koch und ich wir sind
dann wieder für sie da
[Musik]